je prends une photo de cette merde
pour juste savoir à peu près les dates
du monde et c'est magnifique en fait
c'est que des dates
après je pense
bloquer quelques petites
et messieurs nous sommes de retour pour
vous jouer un mauvais tour alors
attendez on va on va chercher les matchs
on a on a eu un petit on n'a pas eu
vraiment de problème mais bon c'est le
temps de venir de se connecter qui est
tout qui marche c'est pas forcément
simple alors attends
du coup comme ça on met ridicalisé en
haut tu sais quoi il est déjà là c'est
parfait
tu pars là-bas
j'ai envie de dire bravo Monsieur
un endroit enfin
j'étais pas certain
qui sont adversaire du jour
alors très flou autour la mine de filtre
flouteries
c'est bon
16 ans à peine
alors
elle va bien qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est la jeunesse c'est nos générations
très fort quoi pour les échelles en
réalité
alors attends je vais mettre le bon nom
on va être bien
[Musique]
c'est une belle journée qui s'annonce
Fab alors attends je les vois pas jouer
non
je le vois pas Google
ouais ben voilà ils sont là et vous cash
ouais on est côté goût cash
3 ou qu'est-ce que c'est que ça et oui
il a joué ma recommandation des parties
pédagogiques
je connais pas tu vois enfin je suis là
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie enfin
j'essaie de faire comme si j'ai jamais
vu ok c'est du bouffe son pion il bouffe
3 fougère
mais après moi je connais pas du tout
j'ai juste 5 ça me paraissait le coup le
plus logique non mais il y a plein de
manières de jouer alors F3 disons je
suis plus trop à jour je devais jouer
plus jeune moi un peu de temps en temps
mais tu peux jouer plein de manières
avec les Noirs tu peux jouer avec E6 tu
peux jouer avec prisé 5 faire le
peut-être des G6 ou G7 aussi
j'ai 6 dames B6 D4
ça peut être embêtant pour des gens de
karaoké
qui connaissent que leur structure ou
quoi ils sont dégoûtés d'avoir ça t'ont
perdus après niveau supérieur quand tu
es un peu plus polyvalent
c'est pas trop dérangeant quoi mais toi
par exemple tu es polyvalent ouais
tout de suite
il prend des cartes polyvalent changer
encore de structure je suis plus
polyvalent que toi
on te ment sur les vidéos quand on dit
il faut contrôler le centre est-ce que
ce serait pas complètement faux
en fait
mettre le roi à l'abri ouais bon est-ce
que c'était bien de faire rock est-ce
que finalement fallait pas aimé garder
le ressent de faire
en Bélier
mais roi de la montagne c'est peut-être
pas mal
là tu vois avec les dames sur les
chéquiers je me dis quand même c'est un
peu risqué peut-être à moins que ma
compréhension des échecs
soit limité mais ouais je trouve que
Rock est un bon coup Antoine qui je me
suis fait ban de la semaine prochaine
pour demander si c'était un film ou un
garçon la présentatrice est enceinte
mérité Antoine BO d'ailleurs on va
peut-être te ban ici parce que tu as
posé la question
il va pas être bien oh tu imagines il
serait vraiment pas bien
sur le truc officiel et tout ce qu'elle
a raison
déjà t'as pas demandé si ce serait
déjà est-ce que tu peux le savoir ouais
non je sais pas enfin bon moi je
t'aurais pas banni pour ça perso mais
c'est pas mon frère mais après moi je
pense c'est un bail complètement mairie
qui peut
aller a perdu au blanc il avait gagné
une partie avec les Blancs qu'on donne
chez codes d'ailleurs en français devant
F3
était magnifique il était complètement
foutu après dis quoi avec les Blancs et
puis il est complètement arnaqué
[Musique]
en fait c'est pas si c'est pas logique
le mec t'attaque ton centre avec un pion
enfin tu le défends
pas l'habitude de voir le plus bouger
mais en fait en soi
pour venir en C5 non mais en fait on va
dire bon si on parle juste de l'objectif
de l'ouverture en fait les Noirs je vois
kaoken pour développer le fout de caisse
blanche
donc si jamais les noirs sont réduits à
faire aussi pas un mauvais coup mais bon
même tu es content
les changer peut-être là-bas
bref mais donc oui s'ils vont pas aussi
ça faut quand même qu'il sache qu'il
fasse parce que
non mais c'est pas c'est loin d'être
idiot ce F3
08 tu es plutôt pour Google ou plutôt
pour égaliser ou plutôt timé F voilà
tu me saoules
en finale enfin Carlson
c'est pas normal que les Russes
participent mais bon s'ils participent
donc il joue quoi
ça dépend des fois dépenses il aime bien
les gens ou pas
dans sa tête je peux pas te dire je sais
pas
question c'est ça une bonne question
pour une interview de Carlson
comme ça tu dois lui arriver assez
souvent de tomber sur des gens qui
pensent qu'ils ont déjà triché
est-ce que systématiquement il joue pas
ou pas
mais ça pourrait être une bonne question
d'interview en fait question qui fâche
on aime bien avoir une question qui
fâche naturelle
est-ce que tu joues si est-ce que tu ne
joues jamais quand tu penses que quand
tu as des doutes sur quelqu'un
bah écoute c'est
non mais le problème actuel en fait
c'est que tu te tire des meubles dans le
pied tout seul quand tu fais ça car toi
tu joues pas tu perds ta partie tu es du
tournoi enfin je sais pas trop et en
fait ces organisateurs de commencer à
faire le ménage quoi
[Musique]
non mais sérieusement oui pourquoi pas
c'est pas un souci
en fait le délai ça pourrait même être
une heure ou deux enfin ça change rien
en fait façon si tu peux pas avoir la
partie
oh tu leur place ce soir quand c'est
fini
ou pas d'ailleurs mais en fait
six mois après tu as un formateur qui
arrive
et du coup on est parti se passe plutôt
bien pour pour les blancs
ou les Noirs non moi j'aime mieux les
blancs mais bon il y a rien de faire en
fait en gros pourquoi j'aime bien je
sais pas je me suis bien avoir des pions
au centre quand même ils prennent de la
place on a actuellement la paire de fou
même si les footcases blanches
pourraient être amené à s'échanger à un
moment sur un fou des trois fuj6 par
exemple
mais c'est toujours je sais pas quelque
chose de sympa et il y a quand même
potentiel d'attaque à El roi pour les
blancs
G5 on a déjà la colonne F donc ça avance
c'est du à l'ouverture avec ce F3
etc quoi il a tort qui peut coulisser
donc
bon il y a un potentiel après les Noirs
en dessin
relativement solide il y a pas il y a
pas Pérille dans la demeure pourquoi pas
un jour songé à casser le centre avec
ses cinq
mais a priori vu qu'on a quand même
l'ordinateur c'est pas du tout un cookie
critique
moi j'aurais plutôt changé à fouger 6
mais peut-être fou G6 c'est bon tu te
fais échanger lequel il est en G5 et qui
a des problèmes j'en sais rien
s'il a pas trop hésité à faire il a pas
pris une longue longue réflexion
c'est hyper dangereux quand même c'est
hyper responsable
ça risque propose l'ordi il faut H7
fouges F5 ça l'a hyper logique et hyper
fort ça c'est classique en général de
faire genre chose ce petit chat
mais bon
c'est vraiment sur la limite hein
et vraiment à la limite avec les Noirs
ça doit être encore dans la normalité
mais tu es vraiment sur la limite
non c'est dangereux mais ouais non enfin
c'est pas c'est pas débile du tout quoi
c'est complexe on va voir s'il y a ici à
mettre pression ou pas
après ça peut aussi tourner comme parti
[Musique]
il y a 5 faibles enfin il y a des bien
sûr il y a des scénarios dans lesquels
ça tombe bien pour les Noirs c'est pas
une position où c'est avantage blanc et
tu as aucun risque en fait si tu te mets
un peu faire le con ça peut
à nous on perdrait quoi
ouais
une partie
c'est le problème d'être nul en fait
pas 100 % mais le truc c'est quick très
bien
et même avec une position un peu
difficile comme avec les noirs
elle est pas assez pourrie la position
pour que ça gagne facilement quoi on en
parlait ce matin quand on faisait la
vidéo si vous l'avez regardé des regga
ici en fait ce qu'il a fait
stratégiquement et Regal easy ça paraît
ridicule enfin j'ai l'impression qu'on
n'aurait jamais fait autant de fautes
stratégie vraiment c'était pour non
cette nuit
mais il nous aurait quand même défoncé
parce que on serait pas mal finir comme
ça a su faire et puis après dans les
autres parties c'est un autre geste dans
le jeu et il avait du Carlson il a fait
deux nuits après
la dernière donc en fait je veux dire
c'est je suis étonné que de devant une
telle partie d'un gars aussi fort
avec elle mais de perdre qu'on a perdu
la première
j'ai rarement des parties comme ça mon
adversaire
autour de 2100 2200 il se laisse pas
marcher dessus mais c'était ça il y a il
y avait un 30 ans
ils comprenait pas trop ce qui se
passait
tu pouvais gagner facilement quoi juste
et là en fait ça a été ça quoi il a
ouais mais après il faut avoir la vista
tactique de Carlson aussi pour finir les
participes exactement parce que après ça
a défendu du côté Riga ici quand même ça
fait mettre contre amateur quoi la
partie ouais
mais en revanche quand Erika ici a dû
jouer de manière tactique là il était
impressionnant
il a beaucoup de points forts
vraiment vite vite vite de plus en plus
de joueurs avec ce profil de
fin calculateur mais aussi parram un peu
dans ce registre
une partie horrible stratégiquement
dès que c'est stratégique c'est mais bon
c'est impressionnant de toute façon on
l'avait vu au 31 décembre
[Musique]
une Vista tactique qui est
impressionnante
mais ouais bon ça a changé
disons je respecte beaucoup plus le
profil Carlson mais en gros ça va être
plus en plus rare
calculer tellement et tellement et
tellement forte tellement fondamental
mais là vous cache c'est propre ce qui
fait le H6 avec cavalier c'était bien
joué c'était bien calculer et bien joué
pour le coup
il tient bien
ils savent que bout il défend
historiquement désolé de te couper mais
ces joueurs Indiens ont souvent eu le ce
profil
et sultan je sais plus comment il
s'appelait c'était aussi un joueur qui
calculait vraiment très bien
mais en gros c'est le premier
[Musique]
qui a permis à ce que les échecs
deviennent ce qu'ils sont maintenant non
en fait il est hyper connu
il faudrait pas enfin tout le monde le
reconnaître dans la rue et compagnie
et donc ouais c'était un joueur prodige
qui est venu un peu en Europe il dit ça
c'est parti il défonçait quasi tout le
monde
et vraiment fort donc énorme carrière
mais avant lui il y avait peut-être
barrière qui était le premier grand
maître ou pas peut-être ça non je sais
pas mais bon ça se bat à rien mais ils
avaient pas vraiment d'autres joueurs
quoi là maintenant
il y a que des grands maîtres en Inde à
13 ans à 14 ans à 15 ans et puis il y en
a plein et ça continue donc voilà et
donc créer une école d'échec ils ont
leur style à eux maintenant
et ils ont pas peur ils calculent pas la
tête s'ils sont mal écrit
c'est bien
et c'est souvent ce profil quand même
de calcul alors je sais pas d'où ça
vient est-ce que c'est genre une
aptitude naturelle
qu'ils ont plus que nous
apprennent le jeu c'est la manière
d'apprendre on sait pas trop hein
je peux pas vous dire
en tout cas ils ont ils ont des beaux
des beaux joueurs
ils ont des beaux joueurs et gokashi en
font partie mais surtout ce goût cash
qui n'a que 16 ans et qui est attends je
vais regarder d'ailleurs c'est sur les
hello parce que il a beaucoup perdu oui
mais ça fait un peu défoncé
à 2007 hein
il est pas bien hein
c'est pas grave
je suis en train de le chercher
il 27 18 il a plus d'élo
et il a trois ans de moins
qu'il y a encore gagné des points et
l'eau en Bundes il y a enfin
2,7 il est maintenant
2736,7 et il vient de passer au-dessus
de mvl dis-toi bien d'où ça tu auras
il a un point et l'autre plus alors
évidemment c'est rien non mais
bah écoute on verra où ils vont tous qui
va percer le plafond de verre qui
s'arrêtera en chemin déjà un très beau
niveau mais on va voir
d'où cette offre il fait une belle
impression en ce moment
il a pris de la maturité dans le jeu etc
très complet
jeunes qui a déjà beaucoup de
compétences dans son sac et qui entouré
par la légende des échecs Ouzbeks
qui a été champion du monde alors certes
feed mais champion du monde quand même
qui a été le second dent de carwana
pendant de très longues années quand
carwana était carburé au top et qu'il
avait
tous ces points forts dans les
ouvertures et donc maintenant il s'est
rapproché de d'Abdou sa torov et ça fait
quand même une sacrée doublette ouzbek
les deux
ouzbeksbeck peut cacher un autre j'ai
envie de dire exactement non mais ils
ont une drafts
un peu en 5e joueur
caché
il y avait
si ça prend tout en G6 j'étais en train
de calculer ça en plus mais du coup tu
as du tout à fait et tu tapes il est en
train de la faire tourner Google moi je
suis quand même plutôt
16 ans à peine est déjà une belle
moustache
qu'il avait déjà 13-14 ans mais là elle
prend de la densité non c'est une très
très belle moustache qu'il a
il a vraiment une moustache au top
il y a pas tellement de gens avec la
moustache non mais j'aime bien les
moustaches donc tu vois ça fait encore
un point positif
je sens qu'il va être beau gosse en plus
non tu sens que adulte non
on demande beaucoup dans le chat à
quelle heure Carlson Naka ce sera à
partir de 19 heures
Ligue 1 winner
à 18h de chez tout le monde
non mais on aura le gars de la qualité
de l'air bien sûr
braquet
là je me questionne tu vois
comment elle est derrière chez Google
c'est très lumineux
ça sent pas le néon quoi
que ce soit juste son éclairage de sa
maison
j'arrive pas à déplacer le truc
un peu bouffé mais bon on comprend quoi
ça me pénalise tu te souviens quand tu
l'appelais
en fait ça décale ça décale tout en fait
je peux pas le faire en fait
[Musique]
ouais mais
une discussion
[Musique]
c'est le quart de finale du looser c'est
vrai
enfin on s'en fout un peu en fait non
mais c'est pour que les gens puissent
plus tard
s'en va de la nuit finale il y aura
qu'une partie
en fait demain on va suivre les
demi-finales de la looser et la finale
de la looser mais la finale non qui sera
en 4 parties de la looser
et donc du coup il y a un joueur qui va
beaucoup enchaîner il va commencer à 17h
qui va attendre qui va rejoindre
mais bon c'est pas mal que
le plus tard possible
avant tu roules 150 bornes enfin tu
arrives tu es en mode Rocky
je suis pas convaincu de F4 mais bon
pourquoi pas c'est pour se faire
chasserico
les championnats du monde qu'on
commentera il y a Vlad qui m'écrit
moi je sais pas
[Musique]
c'est beau
ouais
ça paraît pas le plus court
es
ça marche ça marche quoi
c'est du Moscou Alger quoi
j'aime bien
au moins il l'a repousser
mais il prend les devants
c'est bon un repêchage en chaise boxing
c'est pas facile
pour la mettre un casque virtuel quoi
comme ça
[Musique]
tu meurs chez toi
des gens que tu connais pas
bof tu vois mais là tu vois comme je le
connais je sympathise avec lui et tout
bon là tu vois quand tu regardes
quelqu'un que tu connais tu es chaud
quoi
faut que ce soit quelqu'un il faut être
un peu supporter quoi en fait j'ai
jamais regardé donc
si tu regardes
ça me parle pas trop quoi
tu es content si ils gagnent le coup
comme un pote mais
[Musique]
complètement mais là du coup ça donne
plus envie de voir tu es Championnat du
Monde machin comme c'est un pote en
finale championnat du monde de snooker
quoi
tu as envie de
dire c'est un peu ça cette boxing quand
tu connais les gens après
comme dans beaucoup de choses aussi tu
as envie d'être pour ce que tu aimes
bien quoi
ça donne envie quoi
ma portée que j'aimerais bien gagner
dans les prochaines années non pas
pas particulièrement après il y avait le
tournoi de LFT TFT Nantes tu aurais bien
aimé à l'époque
j'étais un peu actif dans le truc mais
il y a peut-être la Ligue 2 avec
Saint-Étienne qu'on a envie de gagner
j'aimerais bien que quand je reprends le
tennis et ben elle est déjà passé 15
enfin 15 quelque chose puis voilà c'est
plus ça en fait les objectifs
gagnant ici c'est le premier à combien
de temps voilà c'est un bo2
donc à un point et demi
si un partout il y a une armaga
[Musique]
on verra si on y arrive
bon sinon une question qui est mieux bon
plutôt les blancs plus d'espace
possibilité d'attaque le long de la
colonne le centre quand même
mais c'est pas fait il y a pas mais
énormément de faiblesses mais
potentiellement fait de pouvoir attaquer
sur cette colonne g c'est un peu pénible
faut regarder F6 qui veut partir ou quoi
et il y a la pendule ouais 55 secondes
même si à 3 secondes de rajoute ça peut
ça peut vite être maigrichon
complètement
voilà il vient un peu blindé G7 on sent
que ça peut être une fragilité dans la
position des noirs
mais du coup
quoi j'ai un
peut-être qu'on s'est un petit B4 de
l'autre côté
je suis là je suis là je suis un peu
partout
ça peut être un conseil intéressant de
jouer deux endroits différents sur
l'échiquier qui fait la deuxième
faiblesse
à la pendule là je pense aussi ouais il
va rien faire mais 5 secondes pour les
Noirs
si ça responsable c'est peut-être bon
c'est peut-être mauvais j'en sais rien
ça donne la cage G6 donc les H4 ça peut
arriver vite mais il veut faire piéger 5
en fait avec les Noirs il veut venir
planter un cavalier ici plus actif qui
bloque la colonne donc voilà après
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mal à F6 donc ça
donne un cas G6 et ça laisse E6 avancer
créer encore le pion passé quoi donc il
y a du bon il y a du Mauvais en tout cas
il a préféré faire un truc où il
bougeait dans sa position plutôt que
d'attendre
patiemment
il a préféré clique quoi
jolie
de moins ME contre un pion ton roi
de 5 je sais pas tu mets quelque part je
pense qu'il a raté peut-être une
opportunité en fait c'est en plus après
j'ai regardé c'était le coup numéro de
l'ordi ça n'a même avantage noir
mais ça sentait en fait
que ça donne la finale ça peut être
grandiose
je pense je rentrerai avec les Blancs
G2 reprend HG aussi et après tu joues
pour faire des 5 et invasion de la
colonne des quoi
c'est pas mal tu as le droit qui monte
plus vite
proche de gagne en probablement mais bon
pas sûr que ça le soit
avantage en tout cas
les tours tu as plus besoin de ta tour
en G8 maintenant en plus elle peut même
te risotter ton roi
mais ouais ça sent le scénario
mais bon au moins moi j'aurais préféré
qu'on prenne en dessin qui est soit puis
on prend soit que le Nord doivent manger
deux statut c'est plus dur de rentrer
c'est une autre fille
et Pierre vient autant
ça peut ce que tant que tu as une minute
ou deux d'avance tu as le temps de
temporiser si tu si t'en sens le ressens
le besoin mais là ça peut tourner dans
tous les sens je sais pas ça c'était
gaffe d'après l'ordi mais bon
en fait il va falloir dire tu bouges
plus non mais ça on voit que ça bouge
plus
qui ne va pas être éternel qui avait dit
blanc pourra toujours l'enlever
encore une fois
mais c'est un peu le même truc Yeezy
comme carpsen c'est soit tu fais quand
tu as le sens de faire mais c'est
dommage qu'il se laisse mourir à petit
enfin que tant qu'il perde pas tout de
suite il joue un peu un peu la même
école
mais après elle est pas mal comme école
parce que en fait on est
en gros faut pas s'envoyer en l'air
quand tu fais ça quoi c'était justement
un peu aiguillé là-dessus quand
j'y vais dans la même ville c'est un peu
des échecs ensemble qu'en fait c'est
plus dur de gagner contre quelqu'un
contre qui tu vas devoir jouer peut-être
d'un coup fort pour finir que en fait
avoir un truc peut-être même compliqué
mais tu fais trois coups précis et que
ça finit quoi tu demandes plus d'efforts
mais en fait du coup ça dépend ce que tu
juges
par principe mais
bon ok bon bah victoire mérité sur au vu
de la partie qui a plutôt dominé et donc
Sarana et c'est déjà fini alors il
faudra trouver le résultat nous on peut
faire une petite pause ok on a tendance
ça fait déjà 1-0 et on se retrouve dans
une petite dizaine de minutes pour la
suite à tout de suite à tout de suite
attends je mets juste le score
il y avait un décalage de caméra en plus
donc comme ça ça tombe bien mais c'est
rigide qui a marqué le premier point il
faudra absolument égaliser pour vous
gâche à la prochaine je vais mettre une
petite pub et on y retourne
[Musique]
voilà on est de on est de retour et ça a
repris il y a quelques secondes de ça
avec D4 des 5 ça cliquez vite ces quatre
six CA3 et 6 qui est C3 C5
ou C4 ou des trois qui est ici à 3
bon alors en gros le pour mettre le
contexte de la partie Google chez en
mustwin obligé de gagner sinon il serait
définitivement éliminé de ce tournoi
donc on s'attend à ce qu'ils puissent
évidemment prendre des risques à côté
blanc
et
on verra
on verra si il arrive ou pas tout
bêtement
[Musique]
soit il arrive il gagne il y a
l'Armageddon soyez pas il gagne pas il y
a pas la mer
il passe en demi finale donc on pourrait
voir un pion isolé a priori
peut-être qu'on ne sera là
il a peur soit à gagner la première
mais bon
après c'est prendre
après ce que les Noirs ont envie de
faire ça c'est une grande question parce
que à 3 5 ou utile dans les pionniers
qui viendrait sauter dessus pour
retourner vers des cinq
et on pourrait faire une batterie
tranquillement éventuellement et le
deuxième chose à dire c'est qu'une fois
que les Noirs échangent en D4 et qu'on
peut prendre donc certes il nous crée un
pion faible mais ils nous ont aussi le
Phocéen
la vitesse de l'exécution et toujours le
même piège que je m'étais pris quand
j'étais petit
la française
isolé alors H4
est-ce que tu as des souvenirs quand ça
peut être utile ou pas avec Vlad H4 pour
choquer ça sert rarement à quelque chose
mais ça choque mais ça choque non mais
après une fois que tu mets le fond en G5
quand tu fais des dessins et que tu
échanges tout il est pas en prison il
est pas en prise et tu peux reprendre du
pion et ça peut être utile mais souvent
c'est un peu un coup de temporisation
un concept nouveau concept
possible
on espère pour lui en tout cas
j'aimerais voir la suite de son idée en
fait
donc ça donne pas ok
au centre évidemment et
sûrement soit faire H5 soit H3 on va
voir par où comment il va activer cette
tourage mais
clairement il veut l'utiliser par là-bas
quoi
alors bon ouais c'est une conception
spéciale j'ai jamais vu ça on va voir si
c'est si c'est couronné de succès ou pas
OK
bon a priori un coup logique soit pas
laisser le pion pour suivre sa route
plus loin
mais on est peut-être obligé voilà ok
justifierait un peu ce qu'il a fait
et finalement il a avec une course en
train de manger ça c'est un plan qu'on a
pu l'habitude de vendre une fois qu'on a
rocky qu'on a monté par la troisième
année
je trouve
ben j'en sais rien enfin l'habitude de
le voir dans ce sens mais au final la
tour sur une case normale ce qu'il fait
alors après bien sûr pour l'instant on
n'a pas tourgé trois parce que le pion
H5 et en l'air mais bon ça peut arriver
ouais
mais peut-être que doivent pas
spécialement requis vite
du coup
rock ça paraît dangereux mais oui il
aurait peut-être dû
d'attente mais la même position est
croque des Noirs tu es quasiment content
alors tu fais roi F1 et tu te tapes la
tête fais moi aussi
c'est une option
pour ça ok place la tour et on va voir
maintenant qu'on vous cache contre gérer
tout ça
c'est juste femme qui disait que pour
induire l'adversaire en erreur et le
provoquer le petit rock il aurait pu
faire semblant d'avoir fait un misclick
se taper la tête et l'autre c'est ça
après tu fais H4 et bien sûr
et après H4 pour transposer parce que là
en fait avec les Blancs on préférait que
les noirs est déjà ok ça donne à des
cibles d'attaque
que ce soit sur H6 ou le temps j'ai
trois ou G4 G5 peut-être etc alors en 8
pour l'instant on l'atteint pas parce
que torget3 il y a qu'il y avait une H5
à la fois va attaquer la tour G3 et
défendre G7 donc voilà
en D4 donc il était pas prenables comme
vous avez vu mais maintenant en tout cas
il est géré donc même si les Noirs ont
le droit sur une case noire qui a pas de
fou échec en B5 en H7 ou quoi
il y a plus de souci
il va mettre la tour en G3
isolés en fait là et je trouve qu'il le
joue bien non non
ils pensent trop que c'est une faiblesse
le pion isolé
et du coup
[Musique]
il panique je sais pas comment dire
en fait alors que tu peux jouer avec
fait ça pose pas de problème tu as juste
un avantage d'espace et puis tant qu'il
y a beaucoup de pièces sur l'échiquier
en fait c'est pas une faiblesse ça peut
le devenir un jour peut-être mais
il y a trop de gens qui paniquent quand
ils l'ont et je sais pas genre même si
tu fais qu'il y a des seins mais tu dois
faire [__] des deux
tu continues à jouer en fait c'est pas
il y a trop de gens qui prennent ça pour
un problème latent grave dans la
position
alors c'est un problème latent mais
c'est pas si grave que beaucoup de gens
le pensent non ça peut être ça plus de
pièces légère plutôt quoi
et encore c'est plus du tout
particulier c'est-à-dire les dames et de
tout
après c'est bon quel fou il y a aussi
un cavalier contre le mauvais fou le
mauvais vous fait nul
déjà c'est un bon signe pour le pion
quoi
donc en fait il y a trop de cas où c'est
nul et en plus si tu as encore toutes
les pièces dangereux tu as des chances
de gain
donc ça va permettre à l'autre tour de
rentrer en jeu
après il y a ici la cabine une belle
position
non non
il doit gagner absolument il a une
partie où ça joue il y avait pas trop de
théorie et ça joue aux échecs après que
le meilleur gagne
mais
au moins il y a une partie qui va dans
la situation dans laquelle il a quoi
après il faudra encore réussir à gagner
ça ce sera une autre une autre question
mais plutôt sympa de isoler quand tu les
maîtrises pas mal
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a peu de
gens qui aiment les jouets non et en
plus tu peux l'avoir dans plein
d'ouvertures différentes donc en fait tu
peux baser ton répertoire autour de ça
et c'est pas mal
tu peux jouer les deux
non le live je sais pas trop parce qu'il
y a mon on avait dit que c'était 18h45
ça commence un peu après les horaires
sont un peu bizarres honnêtement on aime
tous
il y a pas de
les poses à dure pas tout le temps en
fait on a du mal à comprendre par
exemple là on était persuadé que ça
reprenait à 45 vu la le timing de la fin
des parties sinon ça a repris à 43
et on arrive jamais vraiment à
comprendre
pourquoi comment pourquoi comment
il y a pas un fil conducteur visible tu
peux pas savoir en fait
c'était la nulle qu'il me propose bon
non tu fais comme tu veux en fait de
devoirs
de le faire ou pas tu fais comme temps
ça existe le fait de lui annuler son
coup à l'adversaire
tant mieux
c'est pas par
mais sinon ça m'en dirait les Take backs
c'est pas possible pour un bar
parce que la plupart du temps quand toi
tu vas fermer ce clics on va pas te le
rendre
jamais hein
je l'ai fait quand même tomber après
c'est pas grave
mais bon
un truc une fois après il me fait tomber
enfin tu as compris la comment ça marche
complètement
mais bon c'est quand même posé la
question
belle question d'ailleurs
alors attends on va avoir le gars de
rings
qui va nous parler un peu de l'air de la
qualité de l'air
et presque 18h donc comme ça ça va être
bien ça vous donne une petite
respiration c'est le cas de le dire
enfin
allez let's go je te donne une
oreillette vas-y ou du
Roger
j'espère que ça va marcher
c'est pas la première fois que ça marche
pas
on va essayer de cadrer
alors Émilie
est-ce que tu nous entends
alors attends ok ça y est on t'entend
aussi du coup à l'antenne ok donc on est
là on suit on suit le ring si tu veux
nous voir tu peux nous voir avec un
décalage du coup sur
sur le live
et on est là est-ce que tu suis le
tournoi d'ailleurs avant de te présenter
juste comme ça pour
savoir
le côté échec et cette compétition en
particulier fait partie maintenant
vraiment de de l'ADN d'ersing donc c'est
hyper intéressant de se repencher sur
cette sur cette pratique qui sont les
échecs pratiquais pas mal étant jeune
que j'ai malheureusement délaissé pour
des pratiques un peu plus un peu plus
bêtes et méchantes comme comme le
football et j'en ai presque honte mais
du coup depuis que depuis que j'ai
rejoint RX je me repense beaucoup il y a
eu pas mal d'engouement ces derniers
temps
des séries Netflix notamment au genre de
choses et c'est vrai que c'est une
pratique qui est hyper intéressante à
suivre si tu veux continuer dans le
sport tu veux te lancer aussi dans le
chat boxing qui prend de plus en plus de
place sais pas si tu en as entendu
parler il y a un événement à Paris là il
y a quelques jours je connais pas ça a
l'air un salaire top le chest boxing ça
consiste en quoi alors 3 minutes d'échec
3 minutes de boxe et tu fais des rondes
la vache ok donc l'échec et mat prend
tout son on part sur du chaos et mat ou
un truc comme ça exactement ouais ouais
il y a eu un gros événement aux
États-Unis l'année dernière et là il y
en a un gros événement à Paris vendredi
dernier
au Cabaret Sauvage si tu connais qui
était rempli qui était rempli pour
l'occasion avec avec plusieurs combats
dont un titre de champion du monde en
catégorie en toute catégorie à 120 kg ça
finit sur chaos à 120 kg le mec a gagné
une pièce en 10 coups et dans le rand de
boxe du coup l'autre était un peu tu
vois il était un peu stressé il voulait
mettre des coups et bam ko quoi et ben
ça vaudrait le coup que je m'y penche ça
peut être rigolo bon je suis un peu
moins noble quand même mais ça doit
avoir un côté assez funky quoi ouais
c'est funky voilà après la box c'est
quand même beau sport
on n'est pas encore au MMA quoi qui est
un peu plus
rigolo et donc ouais c'est là pour nous
parler aujourd'hui du coup vous êtes
sponsor du tournoi et toi tu représentes
un petit peu rings en France si je ne
dis pas de bêtises et donc non
je dis juste d'accord
j'en dis beaucoup dans la journée c'est
cool et donc ouais tu pars le nous un
petit peu du coup de de sponsoring de
pourquoi comment est venu l'idée
doudou est venu l'idée vraiment d'une on
va dire d'une peut-être d'une fierté
nationale puisque ring c'était une boîte
norvégienne je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant j'imagine et donc forcément on a
un grand champion chez nous chez eux à
Oslo donc Magnus et donc on a on a
commencé petit à petit le partenariat
avec Manu sans lui expliquant que le
niveau de la qualité de l'air intérieur
impacter le enfin pouvait impacter ses
performances
l'échec c'est les échecs c'est vraiment
une discipline dans laquelle il faut
avoir enfin il faut être bien éveillé il
faut avoir toutes ses compétences
cognitives vraiment alertes pouvoir
analyser le coût de l'eau très
rapidement et pas se planter dans ses
coups et c'est vrai que finalement la
qualité de l'air quand on quand on
supervise des niveaux de CO2 donc c'est
vraiment le un gaz qu'on rejette
nous-même ou des particules fines qui
peuvent venir de l'extérieur de certains
certains types de polluants de
différents types de poussière etc ces
deux ces deux paramètres ont un impact
négatif sur nos performances cognitives
donc on peut se planter on peut envie de
faire des coups un peu un peu foireux un
peu douteux quand on évolue dans un
environnement qui n'est qui n'est pas
sain on va dire et ça a tous son sens
dans la dans la pratique des échecs donc
c'est comme ça que c'est c'est comme ça
que ça a vu le jour on a eu pas mal de
sensibilité de la barre de Magnus et
aujourd'hui ça prend tout son sens
d'être vraiment associé à cette
typologie d'événements pour bien sûr
promouvoir ce qu'on fait nous ce qu'on
propose mais également promouvoir la
pratique des échecs puisque finalement
ce côté négatifs de la qualité d'air
intérieur ça vous impacte lorsque vous
jouez lorsqu'on joue mais ça a les mêmes
effets sur la vie perso un enfant qui
fait cette voir chez lui peut être
impacté par une qualité de l'air
détériorée aujourd'hui on télétravail
quasiment tous c'est pareil pour pouvoir
être performant toute la journée
efficient toute la journée il faut être
dans de bonnes conditions au-delà
d'avoir une bonne installation du bon
matériel l'environnement immédiat est
vraiment clé aujourd'hui
et donc quels sont les produits qui sont
proposés par
things en
relation avec ça on a une gamme de
produits qui est assez variée on a des
capteurs avec écran des capteurs sans
écran on a un capteur type WAF plus qui
est vraiment adapté à une à ce type de
ce type de projet pardon
qui est aujourd'hui disponible et très
facilement on a des produits beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus petits vraiment
beaucoup plus discret des produits de
complément comme la Wave mini qui
peuvent être facilement implémenter dans
une chambre sans que sans que ça fasse
tache c'est des produits qui sont assez
joli bien fini et surtout sont des
produits qu'on peut faire passer d'une
pièce à l'autre ils sont tous sans fil
donc vous pouvez analyser votre salon
pendant pendant une semaine et vous dire
bah tiens la semaine suivante je dors
pas très bien je vais aller voir ce qui
se passe un peu quand je dors est-ce que
tu as des au-delà des produits des
conseils à nous donner pour améliorer la
qualité de notre ère
de manière simpliste donc admettons bon
j'ai une mauvaise qualité d'air j'ai mon
Racing chez moi je vois que j'ai une
mauvaise qualité d'air comment comment
j'améliore quels sont les gestes du
quotidien pour
déjà le premier geste c'est ce que tu
viens de dire de façon très juste c'est
de c'est de monitorer c'est superviser
pour savoir qu'on a une qualité de l'air
qui était derrière ouais il faut le bon
matériel parce que c'est pas forcément
des éléments olfactifs c'est pas des
éléments visuels donc nous on n'en sait
rien il faut être traité et être aidé
pardon d'un outil efficace et ensuite le
la meilleure façon d'améliorer sa
qualité de l'air intérieur c'est de
renouveler son air et ça va donc être
d'ouvrir les fenêtres d'ouvrir une porte
de ventiler mais de s'assurer qu'on fait
entrer de l'air sain parce que lors de
pic de pollution genre de choses vous
allez faire rentrer un air qui parfois
est plus pollué qui vient de l'extérieur
donc il faut faire gaffe à ça aussi et
c'est pour ça que la mesure on continue
est clé mais mais vraiment le réflexe
c'est clair c'est l'immédiateté c'est de
renouveler l'air en aéron en aéroport
après on a une seconde solution qui
arrive dans un dans un temps deux qui
peut être
utile et qui est assez démocratisé c'est
l'utilisation de purificateur d'accord
qui peut et donc là tu peux vérifier
avec avec ton matériel rings les
l'impact direct de des mesures que tu
prends exactement donc tu vas te rendre
compte si tu as acheté un purificateur
d'air efficace ou si tu as acheté si tu
as acheté un joli un joli flyer avec un
produit qui est pas aussi efficace que
ce qui prétend donc actuellement il y a
une réduction de 100 euros sur 200
dollars pardon avec avec le lien que
vous allez voir pop dans le chat il va
passer souvent je sais pas si tu as
quelque chose à rajouter ce que nous là
on a on a la partie qui est en cours on
a on va je vois le chat là qui se
chauffe un peu et qui qui a envie de
suivre la suite aussi
on dit tout de suite que je vous embête
et que ça vous intéresse
pas c'est que là ils sont en train de ça
peut jouer la calife ou l'élimination
c'est pour ça que je te demande ça comme
ça non je comprends tout à fait et je
vous laisse la liberté d'y retourner
c'était un plaisir d'intervenir comme à
chaque fois comme comme l'année dernière
et voilà et c'est vrai que je vous
recommande en France de prendre
conscience d'une essai de la nécessité
de monitorée de superviser sa qualité
d'air intérieur c'est un sujet nouveau
qui a été trop longtemps rattaché au
covid et au pandémie mais ce n'est pas
uniquement voilà lié à ce sujet un peu
un peu un peu un peu triste l'idée de
superviser la qualité de l'air intérieur
c'est vraiment d'améliorer votre
bien-être au quotidien ok bah écoute
merci à toi pour pour tous ces conseils
on espère que les joueurs ont une bonne
qualité d'air en ce moment pour pour
leur partie pour qu'il nous offre un
beau spectacle et j'espère que qu'on a
qu'on a tout dit que ce que tu as que tu
as rien oublié tout est dit merci
beaucoup merci à toi merci à toi et
merci pour le sponsoring du tournoi
c'est normal à bientôt au revoir merci
Fab la qualité de l'air ici elle est
elle doit être bonne je pense on est en
hauteur on est on est bien placé et chez
les joueurs qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pendant
pendant ce temps ça se passe mal pour
bien stabiliser avec son camion G4
et là je vais F5 donc pour pour le
protéger il était attaqué
ouais et donc donc là est-ce qu'il y a
pas c'est en fait je pense que ça
parlait je suis en train de t'écrire F4
d'un projet
je pose la question en fait
je clique pour savoir
et j'ai pas de
OK et si
ici j'envoie du cavalier au 5
ouais c'est chaud quand même
mais j'ai un peu short j'ai qu'un pion
pour ça en fait
peut-être déjà
donc ça sent la qualifie
[Musique]
à parler
donc français 6 soit il protège j'ai
l'impression que ça va être la fin pour
nous cache
à la moustache qui va partir la
moustache qui va nous laisser
complexe et sauf du coup j'attendais par
curiosités
50 pour gokash dans le dans le dur in
the hard il a bien joué avec son Kiji G4
en fait et j'ai 4 F5
[Musique]
du temps c'est un bon plan en fait pour
pour justement laisser la Torah Trump
hors jeu pas la laisser coulisser
j'aime beaucoup ce mot coulisser
tu aimes aussi
je t'ai jamais posé la question si
jamais bien le mot ou pas quoi
et maintenant que contre la pose
maintenant pourquoi pas
il a un pion de plus mais là les pièces
noires sont tellement toutes bien placés
comparativement aux pièces blanches
c'est un peu la merde en plus le pion de
plus il arrive pas assez longtemps il a
les pièces dans son milieu placées
plus qu'à une minute 57 secondes
c'est sur un quasiment
oui bon juste le truc c'est que les
blancs
et ça reste bordélique entre guillemets
qu'il a envie d'un truc plus stable à
base de qui prend 3 qui est
objectivement doit être moins pêchu mais
comme nul peut lui suffire non mais tu
es moins pêchu
témoin péché on va voir après il fait ce
qu'il veut à la rigueur on est là pour
regarder les coups que ce soit péchu ou
pas on est là
pour voir j'essaye de voir sur le visage
du Fab à quel point il est intéressé par
le coup en fait ouais
j'en dors plus la nuit
à demain tu vas devoir faire aller faire
du vélo ouais ça me dit bien
ça peut être déchu d'aller prendre la
dame
fou prendre aussi ce qui on prend
ça peut il y a eu 7 aussi hein bêtement
complexe
on va voir plus de 35 ça peut tourner il
a réussi à faire un truc sympa quand
même dommage
ça ressemble un peu
Dr Strange
c'est pas loin ouais c'est pas loin
mais il a pas de moustache
il doit pas être bien
vaut mieux pas quand même
été bien en division 3 et il enchaîné
partout
et je crois que ceux qui les deux
finalistes de la winner cue là il yaourt
et Carlson ils sont déjà qualifiés pour
le prochain tournoi ok pas sauce cette
fois non d'accord
tu as une minute
[Musique]
en vrai
dans le sens de toute façon elle va pas
bouger
tu as encore le regarder après mais tu
me diras
mais bon d'un autre côté tu as plus trop
de temps
Dornes
sur la pendule
F5 de toute façon il clique pas F5
il a pas mal clic en fait et en fait je
crois qu'il veut
8 t'aurais fuites
[Musique]
c'est chaud encore en vrai
et ça juste par curiosité
carrément bien
donc Wesley Wesley ça devrait y aller
et ça devrait aller normalement
on va voir si il finit le boulot parce
que là en fait bon il a same de plus
peut-être il va pas gagner mais de la
perdre
on verra mais nul en fait la dame ça
fait tellement de perpette B2 et
des pièces ça devrait ça devrait aller
sans Armageddon ici et on va pouvoir
aller vers vers la finale de la winner
cue
normalement vers 18h45 ça peut nous
faire une belle pause Fab ouais c'est
bien ça
bien en forme pour la grande finale
c'est beau hein
bien sûr et là il va pouvoir bouffer des
cinq et une fois que tu as pris des 5 tu
souffles déjà tu soufflais mais tu
souffles d'autant plus
je pense qu'il va faire
il va faire G4 façon
quand même
ça va faire mal
c'est kata
plus de
quoi
il va peut-être récupérer
[Musique]
partie qui va plus avoir énormément
d'histoires non en fait ça se trouve
c'est de créer une sorte de forteresse
tu changes les tours
avec les Noirs en réalité
mais ça me semble pas naturel
naturel non non non non
tu te mets un peu le roi à poil bon
après c'est vrai je suis tranquille mais
bon on va voir écoute franchement c'est
pas encore fini ouais bizarrement
le G6 super
malheureusement tu peux pas échanger
côté blanc
[Musique]
moi j'ai compris il était parti qui
serait bloqué et il a voulu sur un coup
de surprise
je vais essayer de tu vois
de créer l'incertitude je trouve que
c'est pas bête là tu es venu tout à 8
là il va mettre la tour en A6 ils
veulent tourner il va tourner votre
tournée moi je trouve qu'il a été malin
la thoraciaire
je serai parti pour ça
en tout cas il a réussi à mettre en
danger réussi à mettre en danger avec
une dame de moins ce qui est quand même
beau
j'ai trois
mais le problème c'est que tu arrives
pas
il essaie de créer l'accident
puisque je l'ai vu quitter
toutes les camions
qu'il avait non non
live ah oui
ça on peut rien y faire
mais ça j'arrive pas trop à comprendre
pourquoi les joueurs sont pas briefés
là-dessus c'est tellement simple juste
de pas quitter en fait
non mais c'est quand même pas très
compliqué
mais là de toute façon
ouais mais c'est marrant quand même il a
réussi à faire un truc dame j'ai trois
peut-être non attendez 8 bien joué
il va faire quoi
c'est là que tu vois quand même qu'ils
sont hyper forts les deux parce que moi
j'aurais fini peut-être fini par craquer
avec les Noirs si je m'étais retrouvé
dans ce truc là avec les Blancs j'aurais
jamais mis la pression
ah là par contre dame j'ai trois je
crois que ça tu
peux changer 4 il y avait autour des 5
et là il perd un peu
terminé
attention
tu croises
ça c'est terminé et Fab va nous checker
pour être sûrs
donc voilà les deux les deux les deux
donc on se rejoint donc demain on aura
un match donc entre sceaux et airgazing
et le vainqueur aura le droit
d'affronter en quatre parties le perdant
de
ça c'était pour la looser cue
et donc je vous propose qu'on se
retrouve dans
40 minutes on peut peut-être on viendra
avant
cinq en tout cas
on va guetter normalement ça se joue à
18h45
[Musique]
à tout de suite les amis pour le gros
chat quand même
[Musique]
yo yo yo yo on est de retour le Fab pour
le classico
devant la cam on va vous les mettre pour
bien regarder changer les noms on va
tout bien vous faire on se met côté qui
côté
[Musique]
sachant que donc
ça ne
présume rien pour la fin du tournoi non
plus
tu prends comme une petite option
optionnelle
et tu peux perdre une sur deux
ouais et puis en plus
ne pas jouer depuis les chaises
c'est lui qui a décidé d'aller jouer
chez moi
au final c'est pas nous qui l'ont ouais
déjà ou pas
c'est bizarre s'il vient d'être 18h45
mais bon vu leur attitude ils sont
concentrés en tout cas
après je sais pas ça a juste commencé en
fait
c'est bizarre en fait il y a plus
d'introduction plus rien quoi ça
c'est
00 et on va pouvoir regarder les parties
et
les cames c'est bon
les noms des joueurs ça va être bon
aussi
Carlson
[Musique]
après OK
la caméra
et ben voilà on est bien alors le début
le nom il est bien pourquoi
on refera entre les parties alors on se
repasse l'ouverture tranquillou
ok
à ce moment là pour pas laisser 5 voilà
et ça ça rentre dans une grue
on améliore je crois et donc il a pris
voilà avec le pion et il a fait ses cinq
alors je crois et bon à vérifier mais
qui si tu peux jouer C3 avec les Nord
aussi pour le filer comme ça baisser
faire ces cinq maintenant ça dépend
bref donc lui il a choisi ces 5 directs
donc structure plus symétrique mais ou
peut-être les il y aura un peu
quelques temps d'avance pas de côté
blanc
on va avoir en tout cas les carreau qui
est très préparé regardez la dépensé que
15 secondes alors il y a le rajout de
trois secondes et c'est Magnus qui
réfléchit en premier
c'est un peu à mon avis un peu échaudé
il avait perdu contre Rica ouais la
dernière fois en speechasse est-ce que
Ikaru serait pas plus fort maintenant
que que Magnus Fab
bon franchement fort mais bon écoute il
avait été assez impériale
on avait été étonné la belle performance
du carreau qui avait vraiment dominé de
A à Z et là dès le début d'entrée c'est
lui qui met les premiers impacts en fait
très clairement
ça suit côté saumon
qui a l'air bien dans son dans son match
bien dans sa partie et le C5 qui pose
problème alors attention sur des
Français 5 il a encore le temps de faire
ces trois éventuellement pour détruire
la structure et il a joué du coup
cavalier prend ses quatre Magnus il ne
laisse pas oui c'est le plus logique
hein la poussée du pion donc là est-ce
qu'il va prendre en D4 maintenant et
laisser les chevaux arriver ouais ou la
dame ou la dame ouais qui pourrait
donner une position intéressante à
Magnus qui serait quand même en avance
sur le développement il fait fou aussi
ce cavalier ça donc ça a l'air d'être la
prépa ça tape maintenant en B7 mais les
Noirs pourraient se décaler par un dam
C8 ou foud D5 c'est paraître les deux
coups
je regarde en premier il y a peut-être
juste des Français
sur DC on voudrait jouer cavalier à 6
après un récupéré le pion avec ce cheval
un peu à l'image de ce qu'on fait les
blancs ils ont fait cavaler à trois
cavaliers français 4 on voudrait en
faire cavalier à 6 quand il prend ses 5
aussi de manière miroirque exactement
non c'est pas si simple enfin c'est
position complexe Hikaru qui a un choix
cornélien face à lui important en ce
début de match
8 DC qui est assis sur des C6 pour les
blancs
qui peut être un coup évidemment ce
qu'on voulait faire
je peux montrer les coups ils peuvent
nous faire la réponse du berger à la
bergère bergered
du coup tu vois
français 6 ou français 4 ah tu gagnes
une pièce
et là tu es pas bien non exactement
est-ce que tu peux jouer un tour B8 à la
parade peut-être
ça gagne pas toujours
5 il a fait foudre
éventuellement de me prendre deux est-ce
que tu récupères le pion c'est toute la
question
non mais c'est toujours pareil en fait
je
sais c'est comme ça en fait évidemment
les marques peuvent véganiser mais il
faut trouver les coups précis
et c'est pas si anodin que ça ce que les
blancs font
en réalité là il y a une vraie menace
quoi non mais c'est des ventes
une connerie
donc il y a une menace j'ai même pas
envie de dire latente en fait si tu fais
rien pendant deux coups je te fais fouer
3 tours c'est un et merci au revoir et
la partie est terminée parce que les
blancs en fait c'est pas risqué
et ça peut bien tourner donc faut
prendre G2 là maintenant il y a une
réflexion côté blanc pour savoir est-ce
qu'on vient échanger en D8 ou pas alors
probablement non parce que placer la
tour sur la colonne ouverte ça paraît
pas logique mais les échecs comme tu
disais c'est un jeu de précision il y a
des règles fondamentales qu'on connaît
mais après les échecs c'est surtout
du coup par coup et du moment par
momentum quoi
de savoir est-ce que tu les fais ou pas
ça se regarde clairement
aux échecs tu es jamais sûr après non
non tu essaies de décider en ton ami
conscience d'ailleurs il a pris
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il a pris
peut-être qu'il se disait qu'il avait
partir en a 5 avec la garde s'enlève une
des pièces il faut bien tu aurais pu
attaquer ses 5
exactes des machins il a préféré la
supprimer
concéder cette colonne il se dit
peut-être bon on s'en fiche un peu façon
l'important c'est le Punto voilà et bon
le truc comme je dis blanc c'est au pire
tu le perds égales
vous pouvez l'enlever mentalement je
vous aide un petit peu en le bougeant
mais là ce serait égal les blancs
donc bon donc tu as un
ton C8 est peut-être un coup ici
pourquoi pas parce que si on prend ses 5
ça va mal se passer
non attention est-ce que ce serait fini
et quand même fouet
donc bon
si tu fais baisser tu es moins bien à
long terme si tu fais B6 est-ce que tu
vas réussir à le récupérer ça j'en sais
rien
une petite pression c'était sous
pression côté eikao après c'est le
meilleur défenseur actuellement à haut
niveau
normalement il voit bien les tactiques
mais ce genre de position c'est pénible
il fait sa petite tête du carreau il est
en train de voir une variante regarde
il fait sa tête
c'est de la merde
je pense d'accord
final
de winner
qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas la finale du tournoi
d'ailleurs
reprend G2
[Musique]
et là en fait oui donc après l'échange
des dames le problème pour les Noirs
c'est que on a une tour
je le sens dans le trait dur là
bah c'est pas grave
si tu te trompes tu as perdu
il est en train de calculer là
qu'on voit bien là il est vraiment
proche de l'écran petite moustache aussi
un peu pas tout à fait à la gougache
celui-là garde aussi un peu le côté
barbe
mais je crois qu'il a aussi moins de
capacités pilaire je me cache le goûtage
qui m'a l'air d'être quand même
au-dessus
en fait
ça peut être fragile ça ouvre voilà bon
BK
s'il y a pas de malheur sur les cloches
qui avait des
qui est protégé par le cavalier derrière
cavalier prend sur mon front
cavalier prend tour des deux
très dangereux pour les Noirs parce que
même pas sûr
donc cavalier 4 B4 il y a aussi à 5 à
regarder
c'est un détail qui va compter quoi
[Musique]
c'est une variante possible tu as
récupéré ton pion avec les Noirs
c'est pas du tout ce qui s'est passé
dans la partie
ce qui n'a pas choisi de faire B4 il a
choisi de faire Flo 3 qui était la
deuxième option on n'a pas eu le temps
de regarder
là ça va
Sixx bify
[Musique]
important
ouais est-ce qu'il serait pas en train
de s'en sortir tranquillement notre ami
américain écoute c'est le cas il aura
très bien géré c'est pour un parti il me
fait un peu penser à Micha quand il est
comme ça
mais il revient ouais
on peut pas lui enlever d'être expressif
FIKO
le joueur américain toujours
expressif comme Jaja
et mag nos
e
c'est trop facile pour Ikao ça sourit un
petit peu savoir un peu d'eau petite
grimace quand même d'entrée peut-être
une grimace de sortie d'eau aussi
un petit peu de sérieux ici ça va
reborer ça va regrimer
à mon avis il va y avoir une nouvelle
grille massacre qui va partir
après je sais pas c'est très utile moi
je garderai ouvert quelque part quand
même par principe
qui calcule mais c'est vraiment ce que
l'impression qu'il y ait un tel avantage
psychologique sur ikaro Magnus et que ça
a un peu tourné la dernièrement
il est très très bien
il a une très belle position
qui réussit pas à défendre son pion
correctement peut-être il doit quand
même tenter B4 et tour à B1 il peut
faire bien
de regarder quand même
qui fait de la petite grimace quand même
avec qui prend B400
tu peux pas arrêter le calcul ici côté
Hikaru
avec les noirs
si ça arrive mais ça peut ça continue en
fait c'est pas la fin du calcul
notre option c'est quoi la tour D5 comme
option aussi
provoque un peu F4 on va se dire et
maintenant qui est pris en B4 tourba qui
est C2 et la différence c'est que
[Musique]
pour
prendre
trois reprendres 5 mais là
très ratable oui mais ouais
ok c'est un peu bizarre
[Musique]
bon on va dire la première manière la
plus la plus normale
comme position
c'est toujours que les Blancs qui
peuvent être mieux
comme depuis le début de la partie Fab
prend le 5 aussi
par qui est en BK je sais pas comment
dire
ouais non mais on n'a pas super envie
après
n'importe quel moment de la variante
passe on va dire si l'idée c'est de
prendre des quatre après peut-être qu'il
prend des Quatre Temps bien prendre mes
4 à regarder alors tu forces le camion
E5 parce que ça intéresse une autre
histoire
presque tu as vraiment envie
non mais je crois que ce que raconte
leur dit pourquoi il veut faire froid 5
ce qui prend des cartes bien qui est ici
pour ce qui est processus baissé et au
moins tu as pas de pions de moins et je
sais pas mais bon j'aime pas trop donner
le fou comme ça quoi qu'il en soit mais
bon
très concret
non mais j'aime mieux la première
musique
c'est le truc logique qui en fin de
compte a l'air d'aller
tout ce qu'on va à côté c'est plus tirer
par les cheveux déjà moi logique et ça
me fait pas de lire impression donc
ça pourrait potentiellement être kata
les autres variantes
et réellement mal se passer
qu'il va prendre sa décision
sur une dernière vérification il prend
B4
alors à 5 à 3 il va avoir la même
position avec le pion à 5 est-ce que ça
le favorise probablement oui un fable ah
il fait qu'il y a ici 6 OK
donc oui bon c'est le fameux truc ou le
pion vaisselle passe en C6
alors est-ce qu'on est si content je
sais pas c'est toujours l'histoire de la
défaire la case B6 et puis le pion A5
est quand même à la tour à 8 est attaché
à sa défense donc
c'est pas
il est pas bien là quand même
là il est un peu dans le dur
après ce qu'il a fout des cartes on
reprend ses 6
il faut prendre 3
pour DC 8
le problème c'est kaki
3 prises si t'as pas à tour des C8 et tu
auras assez vite c'est la même en fait
sortira par là
avantage Magne
mais il faut qu'il ait le
5 qui est pas évident en visuellement il
va falloir
il est pas si simple
non mais bon
il a ouais mais bon non non mais il faut
la voir évidemment il faut la voir
après l'ordi dit qu'il prend encore plus
fort
pourquoi pas j'en sais rien donc en fait
France a l'air cool la France a
tellement logique je sais pas ça tient
trop de cases
je suis sur ta force tu regardes ton
cheval dans ces quatre
mais bon ce qui est trop fort là tu peux
pas trop te tromper
si ça commence d'entrer par une défaite
oui c'est pas encore fait mais
j'espère qu'il va la tenir quand même 4
minutes Magnus qui réfléchit il a l'air
quand même plus concerné que les autres
jours hein la main ici il est ultra
concentré
il connaît le danger hein il caresse
et du coup qu'elle prend trois tours si
vite c'est quoi le comprendre direct
là
il a pas du tout
il a la finale ça a joué hyper vite mais
pas mal comme ça mais bon il a tout raté
enfin tout ça va mais il a ouais mais
bon là c'est chaud c'est pas 5 de tout à
l'heure mais bon c'est double fourchette
non plus parce que sinon il aurait fait
F ou il préfère ça
contre la caisse de 4
allez final de dames de cavalier aussi
c'est chiant les finales de cavaliers
un des trois
je dirais
et B6 encore c'est encore et
c'est pas comme ça on va rester sur le
direct qui est ici il a fait F5 oui il a
pas voulu voir le cahier
ici donc on va réussir à y aller
mais là il veut Roader trois rois F7 roi
C3 roi E6 roi BK 3D 5 et qui est B
dedans
quand même
toujours dangereux et Caro
il va me manier le cavalier
vraiment tranquille dans cette position
et là tu es quand même sous pression de
duica
comme tu peux le voir pas si facilement
parce que sinon il joue vite
mais là c'est vraiment la pression de
licaru mais lycaro ouais mais roi des
trois il doit se dire il me fait chier 5
rois c'est 3 qui est 4 avec 4 qui est
prend un casque mais oui
on va essayer de la bande en plus
toujours chiant pour un cavalier
tellement en retard je pense pas
mais je sais pas trop quoi
[Musique]
faire cavalier
4 et du coup tu ramènerais le roi pour
ouais je suis d'accord tu vois tout le
long quand même
et essayer de bloquer le truc
et repartir avec le cheval de l'autre
côté et si il fait F3 faire E4 c'est le
liquider les pions et revenir à la fin
avec le cheval pour faire
ça demande des efforts mais je pense
c'est ce qu'il veut faire regarde Magnus
il fait ce qu'il fait ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire et on fait aussi je pense que
la seule manière de pas la gagner c'est
de se [__] trop mal au temps et de se
prendre un piège et c'est ce qu'il est
en train de faire roi des deux
c'est un navigue côté Carlsen
stress en plus avec la pendule donc si
un moment donné il te reste 30 secondes
et Claude te met un piège et tu es là en
train de jouer vite tu peux te le
prendre
mais bon ça joue les calife en finale
bref ça paraît vraiment être seul coup à
moins qu'il regarde cavalier non mais
ouais j'ai l'impression que tu es obligé
de ramener ton roi pour courir un peu
vers là et vers là en même temps peu
comme dans la finale de Retty quoi tu
cours je pense tu dois courir
là il court pas
ça devrait être la suite
ça allait faut jouer vite la côte
il a du calcul assez long la variante
avec elle prend un 4 machins
avant de prendre le pion
pour aller chercher après complètement à
bloquer le roi du tu vois si le roi
blanc et en B5 et tu puisses même plus
vraiment courir en fait
les carreaux qui réfléchit il est mal
aussi ce jouet
BK
c'est là qu'on va avoir si car on peut
créer du jeu je vais tourner qu'il a
réfléchi aussi longtemps sur f736 pareil
par personnellement je pense le problème
c'est qu'il voit pas trop quoi faire
enfin il faut que des positions
perdantes bon il fait le coup de toute
façon un moment faut jouer et tu fais le
truc tu dois faire mais
c'est chiant quoi
la bonne décision enfin tu sais faire un
truc pratique mais attends il fait sa
petite tête de joueur qui a une idée
3 et chaque
roi des quatre comme intéressant et
c'est joué et oui et regarde ça et ça a
quand même ça se dandine un petit peu
alors pourquoi tu veux mettre le
cavalier en C2 donc la robe c'est roi C3
[Musique]
mais tu peux faire
plus de 30 secondes ça va défendre pour
ikaro
plus de 24 secondes à l'aéro commence à
prendre confiance le streamer
F4 c'est logique c'est le coup numéro 1
l'ordi une nouvelle fois
il y a plus de cavaliers
il faut bien que tu montes
ça va être joué F4 c'est trop logique F4
ça aurait été mon coup logique aussi
j'aurais pu hésiter avec le 4 c'est 5
j'aurais eu peur de kbk4 ah il repart
avec le roi vers ah de toute façon
il protège le pion et maintenant il va
les faire chier qu'il va aller au 4 et
ses trois qui avaient lieu de qu'est-ce
qu'il est fort et Caro dans ses
positions
et 12 secondes
et c'est peut-être Hikaru qui va jouer
le gars Fab attention non mais vraiment
attention minus c'est peut-être encore
dominé par un joueur finalement
peut-être plus fort que lui
il tombe sur du lourd aujourd'hui
peut-être quand même pas j'exagère
F3 ça paraît solide comment est-ce qu'il
va réussir à avancer
ce qui va faire E4 peut-être pour
rentrer
allez deux peuvent craquer là c'est
quasiment du jeu à trois résultats
un peu avancé dans ta course ouais c'est
4 c'est un aveu de faiblesse Fab le roi
quitte le contact du pion
ah mais tu as plus trop de constructifs
j'ai 5 il envoie le contre jeux
attention Magnus il a plus qu'une
seconde la moindre déco le problème
serveur chescom attention quand même les
erreurs 505 ça peut arriver
404 404 je crois là pour le coup c'est
Danny qui mange les fils on a encore une
autre mais mais faire attention ma terre
j'ai eu des petits lacs d'une demi- une
seconde sur chiascom attention
[Musique]
aller se mettre dans l'autre coin et
vous regardez l'important c'est du H5
tout à l'heure un coup de gagner ça a
pas été joué par hasard évidemment et là
il y a peut-être faire un F4 échec il
fait G4 c'est un coup tellement
maximaliste il se bloque le cavalier que
moi je serai barré mais tellement vite
paraître un des deux moi aussi mais je
pense qu'il veut jouer avec F4 après
hein il joue avec E4 et il se retrouve
la casse qui est G4 échec
c'est hyper bizarre ce qu'il a fait mais
bon
bah s'éloigner qui
problème
pour Ikao
[Musique]
et avoir cavalier F5 et sacrifier et
sacrifier
il a l'air dégoûté à l'écran
roi B5 va faire cavalier B3
là il faut trouver comment faire
H4
H5 et G3 ça c'est nul direct mais c'est
pas facile
ici il trouve pas
il panique
ah c'est la panique côté Hikaru
c'est chaud
c'est pas dit qu'il a perdu en fait
le chaos tu vois on n'a pas besoin de
chaise boxing pour mettre des joueurs KO
ici
allez il faut revenir faut courir mais
pas moi
il faut choisir la bonne case qui est
ici c'est bien joué il y a pas roi F6 il
va pouvoir venir en E4
alors attention c'est pas encore
complètement fait Fab maintenant
il a envie quelle partie en tout cas
pleine de rebondissements
[Musique]
c'est fort parce que sur
il le fait
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué défense
incroyable du carreaux mais
on peut revenir un sac à quel moment que
ça a tourné
bah c'est son radicap en fait
il fallait peut-être aller juste prendre
le pion ici en France
regarde
[Musique]
puis on prend puis on prend assis j'ai
deux à 7 dames
[Musique]
c'est chiant de t'engager là donc on est
en train de
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
qu'est-ce que c'est bien juger
en fait ok c'est logique et là on
apprend à 4
ça ressemble beaucoup non
mais peut-être que c'est là-dedans que
ça gagne enfin ça faudra un bel ordi et
oui passé des heures humainement et
c'est un bel exercice à faire si ça vous
intéresse de travailler les finales mais
en tout cas qui a le défense quand même
incroyable ICAO
incroyable
qu'est-ce qu'il a bien défendu quand
même parce que la position elle était
censée être
il y en a pas beaucoup grave
ce qu'on souffle de 3 minutes avant le
souffle envie de faire la pause entre
les deux pour pas rater quand même pour
une fois qu'on a un beau match c'est
vrai que c'est quand même assez rare
fais une petite soufflotte
qui fait une petite soufflante il a bien
raison
mais quel match mesdames et messieurs
quelle première partie
extrêmement qualitative
ça a vraiment très très bien joué
malheureusement on peut pas réagir avec
le chat ça c'est un peu dommage
mais bon c'était le spectacle était
vraiment très qualitatif
et on espère que ce soit le cas
dans la partie retour une nouvelle fois
ça a vraiment frappé très très fort
mais ouais cette finale de cavalier quel
défense quand même il a vraiment trouvé
la chance pratique
vraiment bien joué
et donc on attend un patiemment la
deuxième partie
il y a une forme de cette finale alors
c'est quatre parties tout bêtement
bo4
c'est pas encore reparti je crois en
tout cas
mais je pense pas que ça traîne je pense
qu'ils enchaînent beaucoup plus que les
années précédentes en fait
ouais ouais je suis Caro je crois qu'ils
ont arrêté avec les pauses même je crois
même que c'est vraiment 10 minutes max
mais là on est sûr de pas rater
ça serait quand même dommage
à tellement de matchs
qui donne vraiment envie c'est dommage
de pas de pas en profiter pleinement
est-ce que demain tu vas avoir des
matchs de looser enfin tu vois non mais
genre tu vas te retaper la looser que le
machin j'arrête tu es quand même le
match que tu avais vraiment envie de
voir quoi
le tournoi a été fait pour qui et ce
match
non on va dire que sur la liste des
joueurs le seul qui peut les embêter
c'est ça sinon
un autre
mais sinon je crois que c'est un peu
fermé
je crois que c'est un peu fermé
tu penses qu'il va réussir à mettre
pression au blanc
bah déjà je sais pas ce qui va jouer
mais je lui conseille pas ou 4
après c'est le seul qui peut un peu avec
le 4
je voudrais peut-être des choses un peu
plus surprenantes
va pas être bien Manu quand même
non enfin ça va mais
évidemment il a pas l'habitude de ne pas
aimer genre parti mais là en fait c'est
même pas tellement de sa faute enfin
probablement qu'il aurait pu mieux jouer
à un moment ou un autre mais lui il a
plutôt quand même fait sa partie et ça a
défendu la science et tout
ça a très très bien défendu comme ça en
fait tu peux pas tellement t'en prendre
à toi-même c'est la vie enfin je veux
dire c'est pas comme c'était un gain
simple et que tu as pas fait quoi
ça défend bien ça défend bien on
réessayerai une autre fois
oui quelque part c'est la demi-finale du
Winner ici mais là on a pour l'instant
les deux seuls joueurs qui ont pas
encore perdu
mais alors ça commence alors on va voir
ce que je veux jouer carreau il faut que
ça a commencé en fait
les conseils du coach quand même il fait
la même chose
c'est bon je vais bien jouer les trucs
en fait
[Musique]
bah c'est un spectacle à lui tout seul
quand même
à 40 grands regarde les têtes qui fait
non mais c'est ouais c'est mais il
aurait vraiment dû jouer au enfin genre
de Jim qui arrive ou un truc ouais après
ça dépend
en fait quand tu sais ce que tu veux
jouer c'est différent quand tu
improvises quoi je pense qu'il aurait pu
jouer dans le masque non mais sinon il
peut faire une tête de masque et ça
tombait pas ça attends il s'attendait
aussi c'est une western et donc cette
vente là c'est pas con que
c'est toi qui est 4 en général et strat
a des cinq aussi avec les Blancs
il est trop au dessus en fait
mais Magnus il est pas joué un truc un
peu comme ça le dernier round de Bike
contre honnêtement
ça pourrait
vivre vraiment pour les caméras avec
non mais c'est pas possible en fait de
faire autant de à chaque fois tu sais à
quoi t'attendre et quand même et quand
tu es surpris les surpris c'est trop au
dessus en fait
ça c'est un autre coup et aussi ce qui
est tombé tempo
bon en gros c'est très souple côté noir
tu peux jouer avec
avec des cinq avec ces cinq avec E5 mais
bon quand on fait aussi moins mais tu
peux toujours faire des 6 et prépare le
5 plus tard
ouais c'est intéressant c'est compliqué
à ces positions
tellement d'options des 6 dessins
bon
rien du tout mais
du coup de notre balade
par la caméra
[Musique]
il fait vraiment le même âge tu as
raison
c'est beau il a un truc en commun avec
Micha en fait
ce qu'on a dormi
il est là il regarde
tu le sens facile quand même là non
ouais mais bon écoute la partie rien de
faire il domine pas spécialement
c'est que l'ouverture et donc avec les
Noirs faut voir ce que Magnus compte
fait à ce qu'il va essayer de pousser au
5 donc
des trucs par là tu peux aussi jouer
avec ces 5 côtés noir tu peux là je vais
autre chose mais je vais dans le vent
et juste pour dire petit détail
en général quand il y a qui C3 c'est
pour faire 4 mais noir aiment bien faire
qu'il y avait le 4 parce que tu peux pas
de problème de clouage parce que de son
30 jours qui est français 3 attaque la
dame intermédiaire et les deux c'est
pour ça tu te mets dans des clans
donc tu te mets direct dans la merde il
y a pas que voilà donc tu prends des
deux tu fais prendre des sets
et t'es pas bien non
donc c'est pour ça que tu as choisi des
deux et passer trois et
donc OK
parce que là déjà qui voyage 5 ça va
être une idée noire peut-être que
il prend des 4 c'est une idée je sais
pas mais bon
ça peut
alors
c'est possible c'est n'importe quoi
c'est possible
c'est complexe
bon ça servait
et là tu es en carapace totale quoi
et après
par complètement pour autre chose qu'il
y avait trois j'aurais pas pensé au coup
normalement
c'est un peu la spécificité zikao qui
est capable des fois de faire des
placements de pièces très bizarres et
après de retrouver une harmonie et
inattendue en gros ce qu'il veut faire
si je comprends ce qui veut faire des
cinq et avoir la caisse des 4 et on va
repartir
normalement
six classes tout de suite quoi soit tu
vas repartir sur tes pas et tu as filage
6 pour plutôt rien soit d'échange parce
que tu peux pas garder le cloche tu te
fais enfermer le fou c'est un problème
insupportable à regarder je sais pas moi
je le trouve marrant au contraire
il fait que des têtes quoi
toi
mais je crois qu'il y avait un problème
il empêché aussi un E4 un moment donné
c'est pas facile à jouer un compte c'est
c'est méthode horizon là
tout ce qui est moderne machin en fait
si tu prends pas le truc à la gorge
comme ça va dans tous les sens c'est pas
s'il va jouer des dessins que ça c'est 5
rien peut-être dans des Converse
peut-être F5
tu es tu as pas de lisibilité en fait
les noirs peuvent s'adapter
hyper facilement à ce que tu fais
il inverse pas forcément vrai bon c'est
un côté plus simple mais là le fait
d'avoir la paire de fou je préfère les
Noirs honnêtement
façon de parler c'est juste que ils sont
évidemment mieux mais après oui c'est
plus difficile de dire à quel point ils
le sont mais de fou c'est de fou
je vois pas les joueurs énormément
s'hydrater d'ailleurs j'ai pensé parce
que j'avais envie de boire
on les voit pas beaucoup boire non
mais c'est important de s'hydrater pour
les cellules
qui ont besoin d'eau
si tu quitteras bien et que tu as la
qualité de l'air tu es le roi du monde
ne sont pas tester la qualité de l'eau
aussi
peut-être ça s'appelle water signes
peut-être quel genre tu dois voir
c'est pas
à prendre à la légère
bah non
vraiment peu importe ça va peut-être se
jouer là-dessus mais bon on n'a pas trop
assez d'informations
je pense je me Titi
ça boit de l'eau française
non mais en fait le problème enfin c'est
que tu peux bien manger mais c'est cher
que ils ont des bons restos avec des
bons chefs mais c'est vraiment pas donné
et si tu manges le truc normal classique
là c'est pas de la grande qualité
bon ça va j'ai trop souvent les trucs
fontaine que j'aime pas trop en fait je
préfère
robinet particulièrement donc je sais
pas enfin elle se rend potable je sais
pas pour le coup tu vois quand je fais à
l'étranger j'en sais rien je prends les
bouteilles quoi mais l'eau en bouteille
elles ont des goûts différents oui non
je préfère à d'autres mais je veux dire
elles sont pas du tout mauvais quoi
franchement
si on prend ça a l'air
peut-être qu'il veut essayer de faire un
pion prend avec du plage du fouger 2 sur
le 7 mais
sur un tour B8 il y a un truc de toute
façon tu vas devoir la reprendre ta
décision
mais ouais il est un peu dans le dur
c'est t'as pas de choix excellent en
fait faut que tu fasses un peu c'est un
peu
temporiser il va temporiser une façon
faudra la prendre la décision de fermer
ou pas et tu vas devoir fermer je pense
mal au temps aussi mais elle est chiante
mais c'est dommage qu'il est pas réussi
à
mettre pression du tout avec les Blancs
c'est malin ce qu'a fait Magnus
[Musique]
les pièces ou quoi il prend
non mais il est pas content
c'est dur pour ya
c'est dur pour
en plus
E4 pour le coup je sais pas si j'y
changerai facilement mais en soi il est
logique enfin je faisais 5 pour faire de
4 donc si au 4 passe sans avoir besoin
de F5 évidemment sans encore mieux parce
que sur F5 le fou pourra peut-être venir
en dessin
mais du coup moins se faire fermer
si tu peux faire E4 suivi de suivi de F5
c'est idéal et sur le 4 qui est pro et 4
ça a été joué par Magnus
et en gros une structure bien meilleure
tu as toujours ta paire de fou
c'est un massacre pour le moment laissez
pas fait non face en défense mais là
c'est terrible parce qu'en fait l'option
U4 va rester 4 je sais pas si je me
serais pas gardé ce gars sur le Caval
mais pourquoi pas
il va
probablement faire F5 avec le noir à un
moment ou un autre et tu as tous les
plans possibles donc cavalier en 5e pour
la case F3 la case D3
rouleau compresseur j'ai 5 h 5 H4 peu
importe quoi enfin tu avances toutes ces
cases noires
où c'est 3 ou F4 D4 sur la situation
après mais il faut revenir jusqu'à eux
deux quoi
on est dans le trait dur à côté côté
Hikaru oh puis en fait bon on est très
heureux
de faire chasser un jour c'est une
horreur on attaque
il défend le pion honnêtement mais là la
position est tellement dur les pièces
les pièces blanches sont plus aucun lien
mais peut-être tour de tour D2 qui a
validé quatre
ok il vient enlever le cahier des 5 qui
est blanc et il vient aussi se replacer
le pion il donne de la force au G7 vous
la Colona tu feras ses 5 après si tu
éclairs pour c'est la partie d'ailleurs
prise prise et tourner deux
mais Hikaru
[Musique]
c'est son énorme point fort
qui vient prendre le contrôle de la case
des 4
c'est dur là tu te fais manger
c'est extrêmement dur il y a pas de
plomb
pour les blancs
[Musique]
c'est vraiment vraiment compliqué il a
fait foi
il y a peut-être rentrer sur la 7e sur
F5 est-ce qu'il peut avoir quelque chose
[Musique]
plus tard de toute façon
pas bien placé quelque part en réussir à
repasser en dessin
de l'autre côté après on fera aussi vite
nous-même je sais pas enfin
j'ai du mal à avoir un peu ce que veut
Hikaru il veut bon juste pas perdre
direct et tenir comme il peut et voir
après c'est son énorme point fort il
réussit à jouer sans trop de plans comme
ça et refaire du coup par coup après
ouais un peu comme les ordis
[Musique]
mais
c'est contre la tristesse du cheval et
aussi contre ça de la tour tu peux
peut-être échanger tu t'en débarrasse
quoi
c'était pour éviter des tours
[Musique]
n'est pas revenu dessus parce que c'est
pas un coup qui change pendant la
position non mais peut-être pour jouer
en fait
je suppose enfin il veut pas laisser
échanger
pas du tout
moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il veut faire
pour blinder sa colonne
et essayer de faire un truc comme bêtise
Béa c'est vraiment ouais
il devait avoir une idée sur F5 qu'on a
pas vu tu peux checker
un peu la 7e dans certaines lignes
on est on est comme ça après toi
qui ont moins c'est logique ça quand
même alors l'ordi déteste pour le coup
qui est l'ordi déteste le fouet
[Musique]
tours
en ligne
à 4
bon il n'a pas le dame parce que c'était
pas si dur enfin c'est très forcé
c'était pas facile à comprendre c'est
vrai que les coussins en chaîne c'est
dur
mais là c'est un énorme raté de
paradisons il voit des trucs plus
compliqués souvent ouais et puis en plus
dame 7 si tu as bien les chic et en tête
quand même tu crées une menace de menace
trois menaces on ça reste avantageux
pour les Noirs mais c'est un gros gros
gros gros gros raté
je sais pas si carole a vu je regardais
pas sa caméra à ce moment là
de toute façon maintenant c'est passé
peut-être les deux joueurs l'ont raté
mesdames et toi en fait il y avait rien
à faire parce que maintenant en fait il
y a plus le pion à 3h tu peux réussir à
faire le setup dont je te parlais tout à
l'heure avec le fond en B5 du coup le
pion A4 et des idées de changer
et si tu réussis à liquider la dame tu
t'approches quand même oui
5 ouais bon bien joué évidemment il veut
profiter du fait que le fou soit parti
de l'autre côté enfin il est pas encore
que le temps parti mais s'ils vont
baisser 50 en tout cas ça sera le cas
pour aller ouvrir la loi la question
c'est est-ce que tu calmes un H4 est-ce
que tu fais tout a à deux et tu
t'enlèves du vis-à-vis
qui est quand même dans le dur il doit
regretter à une ouverture complètement
ratée
catastrophique trop de coups
aux autres il cumulent et ça fait une
mauvaise position à la fin quoi
commence à piocher sévèrement dans sa
pendule
il reste plus que deux trente le temps
qui s'égraine de plus en plus vite de
plus en plus fort
E
c'est pas une bonne partie c'est une
très mauvaise partie
donc on va voir si réussi il a fait H4
on va voir ok peut-être fallait faire
mais toute façon c'est pas bon signe tu
donnes voilà tu donnes du G5 au noir un
peu quand ils voudront
bon pour l'instant il était juste d'un
proche 5 dessus ou je sais pas donc
c'est pas dit peut-être
et tu as sens à te presser pour se
presser
depuis le début de l'ouverture
encore 2 minutes d'avance et si Magnus
bon la première comme je te dis c'est
vraiment une belle défense des carreaux
mais il l'a vu son genre position et
toujours pas c'est qu'on se pose des
questions tu dis mais il me faut quoi
pour gagner quoi
c'est complexe
ça fait peur mais bon quand tu vas faire
j'ai 5 qui va prendre tu vas prendre il
va faire G4 il y aura dame G4 quand même
toujours
faut qu'il s'organise pour pas pour rien
perdre mais il peut peut-être la tenir
non mais c'est ça qui peut me gagner
avec les Blancs
tu peux t'énerver là il reprend
confiance
qui craque une nouvelle fois
complètement cinq ou étonnant parce
que t'en viens en fait et les blancs
j'ai un petit lac à 5 alors après pour
le coup évidemment
il veut jouer un peu sur des clouages
ils compagnie quoi donc il y a pas de
Messi pour l'instant mais même un coup
comme toi tu prends à 5 et prends à 5
ans
mais mais là
c'est peut-être ikaro qui favorise la
partie au vu du scénario ça me fait
penser à ce que m'expliquer mon coach me
retard c'est le dernier qui met les
coups de position
c'est un peu comme la boxe et là les
couilles ils sont mis pari carreaux
parce que là Magnus vraiment H5 enfin il
prend H4 tourachide tour D8 là c'est
c'est un peu la panique
c'est marrant parce que pendant des
années des années des années des années
c'était son client
Ikao
il était complètement dominé par Magnus
et là c'est comme si c'était l'inverse
maintenant
et oui enfin c'est toujours pareil dans
tous les sports à un moment faut être
réaliste ouais mais tu as l'impression
que tu sais ça fait penser c'est comme
si il était de mettre derrière la ligne
de fond et carreaux contre Magnus mais
en fait il courir mais toutes les balles
et Magnus si s'énerve et il arrive plus
en fait parce que c'est avant il réussit
à mettre tout le temps le point donc bon
c'était facile
reviennent toutes il y a une certaine
longueur et la confiance a changé de
camp regardez Garou très heureux non il
a dû soulagé enfin il a plus la même
attitude
il reste très concentré évidemment pour
pas saccager tout le travail défensif
fait jusque là mais il faut acheter
le coup de panique à un moment donné il
a ouh ouh ah bah oui
un peu ko enfin un peu gros
mais attention parce que il a une
position pas trop dur à gérer autant la
celle-là elle peut
tu sais pas quoi
faire
comme tout à l'heure et c'est pas du
coup par coup quoi
tu peux pas faire nul là
du tout
[Musique]
seven Knight be five tu as des idées de
partout quoi
regarde plus qu'une 34 pour Magnus moins
bien autant maintenant
oh il est complètement
oublié que tu étais gagnant
ok c'est parti
en ordre ouais mais tu as plus trop de
temps là tu as plus qu'une 10
plus qu'une 5
minutes de la partie
physiquement ça a changé
positif et Magnus aux abois en plus ça a
été très move
ah non mais il lui met tous les tous les
fondamentaux
qui a l'air déterminé là ça danse oh ça
danse ça chante
et ça me va absolument tous les coups
[Musique]
peut-être un monsieur de ouais après la
position je prendrais quand même les
Noirs en toute objectivité
[Musique]
donc oui
de toute façon
il peut y avoir une couille un moment
donné je sais pas bon après il faut pas
jouer avec G5
les noirs qui ont l'initiative du jeu
je pense que les deux
pas simple à jouer encore la partie pas
et pas fait
je sais pas ce qu'il veut
et ça peut aller dans tous les sens
[Musique]
cavalier
de nouveau
sinon on peut faire c'est quand même une
option il va pas le faire je pense
mais ce serait pas perdant pour pour les
noirs
pour B8 ah il va tout échanger
il veut passer devant F5
et le roi tu le mets où en deux à droite
à gauche
et c'est nul signé
qu'avant c'est
une belle défense en face soit tu prends
le risque d'aller bouffer le pion A4
mais tu laisse leaser et ok c'est chaud
tu peux vraiment la perdre la scène là
c'est écrasant quand même il finissait
sur le champ et c'est pas comme ça un
coup c'est
pour la pause 5 minutes je garde
l'antenne
faire quelque chose ok fais donc je t'en
prie ouais donc écoutez des mecs de
match pour l'instant Magnus devine
dans le contenu mais pas dans le
résultat pas de réalisme et quand c'est
comme ça souvent j'ai tendance à penser
que ça peut sourire justement aux
joueurs
qui était dominé et
qui en fait s'accroche donc peut-être
avantagika elle a évité de partir comme
je vous dis pas dans le contenu mais
fait que toujours un partout qui lui
donne nul parce que ce qui s'est passé
dans celle-là donc moi je vous repasse
la partie si vous voulez on a eu cette
ouverture un peu Réty Magnus qui joue
avec B6 donc comme il avait fait la
dernière ronde du tata style
pourquoi pas enfin moi je connaissais
plutôt soit des 5 soit qui croit ici
mais bon tout relance c'est un cours
raisonnable ça place la tour au centre
ça peut appuyer 4 ok
E6 ku souple alors évidemment il y a
sûrement plein d'opportunités et de
possibilités côté noir mais aussi ça
mange pas de pain parce que on peut
ensuite jouer avec ces 5 sans faire
penser fermer on peut quand même jouer
avec des sites 5 peut-être ou des cinq
donc regarde absolument toutes les
options côté noir
développement peut-être pas très bien
senti parce que ce fond on a senti après
dans la partie qui est pas trop bien
placé ici
il y a eu des six il y a eu des deux
donc pour essayer de faire le 4
mais en fait c'est pas ça et qui avait
300 par contre pas aimé je sais pas
pourquoi
j'ai du mal à capter
en fait à travailler pour
tu prends le centre alors après
évidemment ce fou pour être force
diagonale c'est moins solide ou quoi je
sais pas mais bon là
donc
mais j'ai objectivement les blancs ça va
jusqu'en vidéo est quand même très
bizarre il devrait être là parce que
quand il est là quand il y a 5 au moins
on a une meilleure case ici bloque pas
la colonne enfin même chelou donc je
sais pas qui est bizarre en fait
c'est plus là après ce que j'ai tenté en
live c'est de dire que ça du coup c'est
une option sur kit C3 alors pourquoi
parce que c'est 3 donc vous avez compris
on veut faire 4 les noirs n'empêche
physiquement et voilà juste sur le quai
en des deux les noirs peuvent pas
empêcher physiquement comme ça parce que
on se retrouve dans le vis-à-vis et il y
a des gens qui G5
c'est celui-là il est Chloé s'il prend
l'un ou l'autre on s'est bouffer B7 et
ça va pas alors si le caillou en C3
cavalier 4 et qu'on fait le même coup
bon c'est pas grave on prend ça et on
touche la dame donc il y a pas fonder ça
donc on va reprendre et bon peu importe
là on a juste doublé des pions gratos
c'est peut-être ça ça devient une
faiblesse qu'on va pouvoir attaquer plus
tard donc avec peut-être la dame qui en
parla le cavalier par ici ou faire ses 5
tours C8 enfin bref on va retrouver des
idées
en position de défense mais en fait ça
se passe très mal donc il remet à
l'hiver des cinq ça c'est un très bon
coup il ouvre le fou
faut prendre
ces trois on peut pas reprendre on parle
fou et si on prend ça il se fait bouffer
ça on prend B7 sûrement ça
prise et ouais ça peut la merde ok ça va
donc ok il a dû tolérer au 4 et là bon
juste si on prend une photo de la
position évidemment c'est kata parce
qu'il y a paire de fou un fou super
actif sur la grande diagonale celui-là
en muret lui est nul la colonne des
c'est une heure qui vont la tenir
beaucoup de problèmes et là il Caro a su
faire le dos des formes B2 bon admettons
ça j'ai bien aimé il améliore sa
structure enfin me dérange pas il y a en
tout cas il a l'air sa tour il va faire
ses seins qui me donne tout voilà
j'étais pas trop sûr moi je pensais F5
perso mais en fait c'est pas un des top
coups de l'ordi c'est pas dans le top 3D
donc bon ce qu'on a cru comprendre dans
Live c'est qu'il veut bien contrôler
cette case pour mettre une tour
à trois
prises alors là étonnant il a pris du
pion
attendez 8 donc c'était son plan fous
des 7 et là c'est là qu'il arrête le
gars en fait un gain
donc on est en fait on recule la dame on
attaque cette tour on libère le fou donc
ça peut être là ou là mais bon on a
regardé dans le 7 donc bon voilà
clairement de se faire [__] en toi
bêtement donc la tour il faut la sauver
donc il y a une case de case 3 cases
alors le problème de ça où ça de toute
façon c'est que les Noirs qui comptent
faire c'est 3 pour attaquer cette tour
qui peut pas bouger à droite ou à gauche
parce que celui-là il est perdu donc
elle doit rester sur la colonne des pour
défendre son four et il y a pas 50
choses là il y a le pion voilà ça a pas
non plus ça a pas que des six [__] on
y va sauf que maintenant elle est plus
trop protégée on attaque deux fois plus
ou moins enfin vers lui il est là mais
je veux dire il y a deux pression dessus
il y a que la dame qui défend donc si on
rattaque le fou il pourra pas s'en aller
faut aussi vite et
problème c'est quoi version prend on se
fait bouffer enfin bon juste ça perd
quoi voilà
donc c'était pas possible si on se dit
ok je fais tourser un comme ça il y a
pas fou ces trois mieux on va mieux Viny
on perd quand même un pion déjà pour
commencer et en plus il y a toutes
sortes de doubles de surcharge on va
dire sur la dame elle défend le cavalier
elle doit aider la défense de décès ce
danger ils peuvent plus prendre ça s'ils
veulent et donc problème et en fait ça
juste un soluble après dame 7 son
attaque ça et tous les problèmes avec le
fouet 3 et qu'on vient de voir alors
dame c'est 7 avait l'air de marcher
aussi avec plus ou moins les mêmes idées
et gros raté de pas la refaire du coup
A4 sur fait d'un seul au moins
maintenant ça permet de renseigner il y
a plus le prix en prise bon ça reste pas
brillant pour les blancs mais je veux
dire c'est pas foutu direct e-lyco
punition
minus a voulu avancer là-bas il y a eu
H4 pour bloquer il ajoutera ensuite
sûrement pour jouer avec G5 mais
carreaux sans laisse pas compter contre
attaque de l'autre côté
alors peut-être qu'il était quand même
temps de faire G5 qui est compliqué le
jeu à fond je sais pas puis on prend
dame prend on touche quand même un peu
cette tour on menaçage 4 fasse semblait
être dans le sens de ce qu'il a fait
après évidemment ça se compliquer enfin
je vais faire quand même Mathis ce roi
ou quoi mais il y avait
semble pas bête il est revenu sur ses
parents en fait je sais pas ce qui lui a
pas plu mais un truc qui n'a pas plu il
Caro je tends bien plutôt bien joué
l'idée en fait c'est que s'il est noir
prennent ce pion les blancs peuvent
prendre je sais pas lui ou lui en tout
cas l'un ou l'autre pour que la tour
aille reprendre en B7 et regagner le
pied droit donc il a pas fait
il a bougé il a reculé son fou et puis
ça s'est un peu échangé petit à petit
voilà alors après peut-être une
opportunité noire ou pas notamment là
attention il y a les pièces qui
regardent et puis un sacrifice donc il
Yao c'est dit comme ça en cas de prise
puis on prend dame prend il y a pas
Échec donc là j'ai le temps de mettre en
place en défense et par exemple ça a
l'air fort échec et on revient que le
métier
donc Manu ce n'est pas les sacrifiés il
a fait tomber vite
ok on échange tout on joue la finale et
il a replacer son fou
ils ont fait nul là parce que s'il vous
prend faut prendre faut toujours reposer
et ciao il y a plus rien
bref mais comme on le voit Hikaru s'en
est juste très bien sorti parce que
il est passé proche de correctionnel
et vu que ça se passe comme ça et ben il
a il a encore il a encore ses chances
dans le match
donc voilà pour le contenu donc la
prochaine round Magnus aura les blancs
[Musique]
peut-être encore une rétine il a eu ses
chances dans la première mais donc voilà
ça fait deux parties Windows
attention ça peut se retourner contre
lui un moment ou un autre
donc après j'ai pas d'infos sur ça
reprend mais normalement il traîne pas
trop c'est plus ou moins 10 minutes de
pause entre les parties
donc
je sais pas à quelle heure on a fini
celle d'avant mais je pense d'ici deux
trois minutes ça va reprendre
alors il y a xabajou qui me posait une
question il y a un moment il dit pour la
partie j'avais dit que il fallait être
agressif il aurait dû faire quoi
concrètement bah je pense alors soit tu
auras c'est pas assez vendre l'ouverture
et c'est mieux de faire que ces trois
dessins mais en tout cas mettre quoi
après il a trop attendu
la suite bonne question il y aura un
armée donc partie décisive qui décidera
du grand vainqueur
bonjour fais un récap de la partie quoi
elle voulait faire sa petite sortie mais
je sais pas si en 10 minutes j'aurai le
temps
donc la partie qui doit repartir
normalement ouais partout tiens
un parcours
balle au centre
c'est le cas de le dire ce soir parce
qu'un autre classico ce soir femme ouais
en Coupe de France un petit peu
qui doit commencer à 21h j'imagine 21h
ouais sur France 3 c'est bien du foot en
clair ça fait toujours plaisir c'est
devenu trop rare maintenant
toujours sympa d'avoir
des classico et c'est reparti pour notre
classico femme avec une Nimzo alors ça a
peut-être être une ragosine est-ce que
le cavalier va venir en C3
[Musique]
et tu dois faire des cinq et en gros tu
as juste un grand bidame gratuit je sais
pas si c'est grave ou pas mais
on a fait une vidéo avec Mathieu sur
cette vidéo la vidéo la variante
vintoline charmante par vintolinch OK et
alors c'est ça
[Musique]
pas du tout logique parce que tu te
retrouves à décaler un pion à doubler un
pion là-bas en B4 mais tu contrôles les
cases
mais ça trouve ça logique quand il
réfléchit mais après ça a été trouvé
sans ordi parce que
c'était une autre époque
[Musique]
quand tu as la position comme ça même
quand tu sais que ça va c'est bizarre
quoi
c'est pas c'est pas logique
mais tu trouves cette logique mais une
vidéo sur la chaîne faite avec Mathieu
ou c'était une partie d'une tenue
justement
très très belle partie
mais ouais c'est pas logique d'échanger
un pion central qui contrôle le centre
de base contre un pion a qui contrôle
qu'une case
et tout la tour
mais tu te donnes du jeu tu vas arriver
à développer ton fou en B7 qui va me
faire des trucs sur la grande diagonale
tu parles quand même jouer avec des 5 si
tu en as envie et donc il est bien
quand on était ici et puis on BK
c'est toute une histoire non on avait
fait la vidéo comme je disais avec
Mathieu et potentiellement un jour tu
peux avoir si tu fais des seins et que
des c'est quelque chose qu'on ne sait
une structure qu'on voit souvent dans
les
dans les semi-raches on va dire alors
d'habitude l'option B2 il y aura deux
mais où tu as ton histoire de majorité à
l'eldame quoi éloigner ouais
c'est incroyable à l'époque d'avoir eu
cette idée de
me sentir que c'était bon
quelque part entière
très antipodes mais très intéressantes
de sortir cet arme un peu de la botte
qui s'est sorti deux fois de mauvais pas
est-ce qu'on va avoir une partie qui
temporise un petit peu plus dans celle
là
en tout cas le match est assez agréable
à suivre
on a des parties animées disputés qui se
finissent souvent au bout du bout
et ça ouais ça joue cavalier B4 et oui
on voit une autre utilité en éliminant
le pion à deux c'est donner cette asb4
pour le cavalier qui n'est plus contrôlé
et tu contrôles les cases les cases
blanches en fait centrale
comme tu disais tu rends chez Nike dans
tes essais tu as tout FC 8 taper un peu
sur ce pion
etc c'est loin d'être fait mais là tu
peux même te permettre d'ici sinon
bêtement
[Musique]
mais du coup peut-être qu'on fait pas
des 6 juste je déteste tolérer un
j'aime pas tolérer des pièces dans mon
camp en fait
ici ce sera un planche en suivant d'être
mon être sûr
ouais bon je connais mal c'est position
je peux pas trop de dire vu comme ça je
peux pas te dire non c'est débile ou
quoi je sais pas
pour rien soit ça paraît pas idiot
la petite turbine recommande à 5 je le
ferai pas
tu as fait bu une case quand même mais
bon elle est vraiment utile c'est
compliqué oui en fait faut une certaine
expérience de la position pour dire
la position
pas commun comme structure indéchanger
c'est contre
ah ça doit bien convenir à carou ces
trucs là un peu bizarre un peu
un peu asymétrique
mais bon au final
plus scolaire qu'on ne le pense non et
plus universel quoi c'est bon toi quand
il se passe pas grand-chose il a bien
appris sa théorie
il est solide avec quoi il n'a pas
besoin que ce soit toujours fou dans ces
parties il a pas longtemps je veux des
grands bidames très solides le petit
classique avec fossette
donc
en fait il peut tout faire quoi
juste ça me semble
et tu t'engages à rien quoi
tu peux pas tu aimerais bien mais tu
peux pas
[Musique]
beaucoup de tempo pour pas grand-chose
mais bon
pas évident à jouer non
il écoute
enfin de l'ordi je sais pas
du tout
déjà même si c'est un ordi pas très fort
si le propose c'est que le coup est pas
une idée allez j'essaie de comprendre ce
qui est une sorte de profil aussi quand
il y ait des traces peut-être tu veux te
lancer vite
c'est même pas ça alors
et comme ça sur dame B3
[Musique]
ok toujours
comprendre l'idée de A5 de en fait de
laisser bouffer en bécane apprend B et
de faire une fourchette ça je me barre
avec la tour au paquet tu reprends tout
à la fin mais il faut assise même idée
et puis pressé mieux donc ok au moins on
comprend à 5 pourquoi
donc oui donc le défaut de A5 15 B5 et
aussi pion V6 des fois sur qui avait la
4 si jamais mais pour l'instant ça
libère la tour aussi qui t'a lancé 8
c'est économise du coup dame 7 qui
faisait passer l'autre tour
et on va pouvoir jouer un truc comme
tour C8 fois 6 et si les Blancs jouent
avec B3 on aura des singles ici puis
arrive en B3 qui a une tour en C8 elle
sera en face du cavalier et du coup il y
aura une situation de clouage et le
deuxième truc peut-être qu'on peut jouer
des 6 au prochain coup aussi qui ait des
trempes parfois 6
un autre plan qui peut exister un petit
répare les cheveux ce serait d'essayer
de faire passer la dame en 8 ouais bon
d'habitude
enfin à noter que peut-être un jour dans
une variante un A8 pour aller taper ça
peut exister de toute façon c'est
toujours bien de remarquer des trucs
comme ça pas jouer pour le faire
absolument mais si avant l'opportunité
comme si comme tu l'as remarqué
et d'ailleurs ça peut être différemment
peut-être tu auras le fond en C6 un jour
et tu passeras la dame en B7 ou
inversement mais de savoir que tu as tu
peux avoir une idée de batterie
même arrivé comme ça j'avais un exercice
bon tu as des fous prangers tu as une
dame qui arrive en G4 et tu es un
perpète voilà on en est très loin
cette idée là un peu marrante
je sais pas si tu as déjà réussi à la
faire en partie
je crois pas trop mais sacrifié un fouet
comme ça
ça me fait peut-être penser à une nul
qu'il avait fait à vos jamis
de comme ça
en tout cas
en tout cas il y a cette idée de
de fou qui vient assise de taper ce pion
qui existe
donc un mètre proche de l'égalité en
réalité ouais non mais ça a du sens tu
veux faire tourner
et puis en fait pourquoi pas en fait tu
fais tout sur ces 8 décises de 5 à un
moment oui
même avec les Blancs tu as du mal à
l'empêcher
il va bien en trouver quelque chose
il va bien trouver quelque chose Magnus
pour continuer à mettre la pression sur
eau à chaque fois
en tout cas cette fois-ci on a vraiment
l'impression d'avoir une position qui
convient à Hikaru
bah dans la deuxième partie c'est avec
quand même plutôt l'air de convenir à
Magnus et la première ouais ça lui
convenait mais finalement elle était dur
à jouer enfin c'était juste un une
position difficile donc là c'est la
première en fait dans le match on a une
position
et il a une position qui lui convient
et ça va la pendule
ce qui est quand même important toujours
en partie rapide
clairement
ça rentre en ligne de mire
non mais ouais je pense le coup je
comprends va à 5 du coup bien joué
maintenant qu'on a compris pourquoi et
qu'on voit un plan qui va avec avec des
fils de 5 et 38 ou pas intégré
épuisant pour réfléchir comme ça alors
oui non enfin en fait oui ça va être
fatiguant mais ils ont l'habitude donc
tu finis pas la journée en pleine forme
normalement mais c'est l'habitude de
répéter ces efforts quoi
enfin ce type d'effort
focus pendant plusieurs heures donc
c'est un peu le même genre d'effort que
si
c'était des partiels ou des exams et que
ça dure sur une semaine et que ça prend
6 heures par jour enfin ouais
c'est un truc qui s'exerce quand tu
commences jeunes les déchets etc
un peu cette habitude là quoi tu sens
moins la fatigue que si tu commences
comme ça d'un coup et que
une demi-heure plus quoi tu t'amuses
aussi
oui
non mais là il s'amuse aussi en quelque
sorte c'est dur mais je veux dire par là
c'est un jeu enfin je sais pas
je pense qu'il kiffe quand même
non mais j'espère mais des fois tu
le stress à gérer aussi 21 en jeu tu as
des jeux
du monde pour un truc comme ça et tout
les mecs perdent du poids etc mais là je
pense pas non plus que il soit au bout
de rouleau au bout du rouleau ouais
tiens tu vois l'idée on peut là on peut
la retrouver un peu dans cette variante
là
et du coup t'as pas cavalier des trois
qui aurait pu être fort parce qu'il y a
je sais pas enfin je sais pas à quel
point il s'amuse je gère ce stress de
jouer aux échecs soit tu l'as tu l'as
pas en fait et si tu l'as pas tu l'as
jamais et tu es juste dans le dans la
joie de jouer mais prenons pas exemple
de Vlad ça va pas d'amuser de jouer un
truc sur internet non mais il y a 10 ans
il est beaucoup moins stressé enfin tu
vois et beaucoup moins
machin tu sens que et
carreau il a dit que c'était cool ça
faisait penser à autre chose je les
événements donc
non mais évidemment c'est pas un effort
facile mais je veux dire je pense qu'il
préfère ça à 6 heures d'exam 7 jours
d'affilée avec les révisions le soir
non pas des têtes de kiffeur ouais mais
bon quand tu es concentré tu kiffes à
postérieur quoi
quand tu joues
alors ça c'est une trop grande
différence de niveau et tu peux jouer
comme ça mais quand il y a du répondant
je vois des détails quand même
c'est exigeant on va dire ça peut être
fini
à 2 pour échanger le cahier B4 c'était
pas mal joué mais d'ici c'est j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même une
carreau qui met un peu la pression ici
peut-être pas encore sur la position
mais tu vois il commence à avoir le
temps qui se dessine la position qui
convient vraiment je pense que Carlson
qui en fait c'est s'il a vraiment rien
et qui jette les blancs la poubelle
comme ça quoi mais bon à force de
vouloir
regarder ce particulièrement et c'est
c'est peut-être une option aussi
à toi
logique mais après si D E est plus fort
si ça marche
en fait AB ce qui semble logique c'est
que tu crois que tu réhabitues donc ça
force KF3 et peut-être Damas 2 du coup
tu rentres un peu
donc ça
ok ça a l'air enfin cool
la Colonna tu vas pas faire grand-chose
mais déjà les blancs la prennent pas tu
attaques un peu B2 il va faire je sais
pas
[Musique]
ouais bon ça c'est le scénario numéro 1
voilà en numéro 2 c'est que tu prends ça
le cavalier va devoir s'en aller quelque
part
on prend disons
c'est dur à dire
alors comment je préfère
des ruptures des B5 des machins je suis
content quoi
non mais oui je pense que c'est
équivalent
à moins que le roi arrive en B3 dans la
finale oui mais bon on en est loin
le temps de faire deux trois trucs avant
ouais mais c'est quand même enfin moi je
trouve que les deux scénarios c'est
quand même cool pour les Noirs alors
c'est sûrement le billet cognitif de
quand aller noir tu as l'impression des
fois quand tu as égalisé que tu es mieux
par habitude mais quand même tu es
content et car oui il a l'air content
regarde il est content quoi
dire je suis bien
non non mais là au moins il est pas en
train de galérer à défendre un truc
au bord du gouffre
ça veut pas dire que c'est peut-être pas
celle là qui va perdre au final mais
Emmaüs a contrarié il a l'air deg ouais
mais tout le temps enfin pas trop
expressif
c'est peut-être juste deg de jouer
depuis les chez les bras en fait
chier toute la soirée il y en a marre
quoi
[Musique]
un truc à la fin ça c'était dans cette
ligne là
je suis content
avec idf3 ou C2
non en fait ça j'ai raté de calculer
mais je pensais que les Blancs elle est
juste sur qui le 4 à faire du sien ou je
sais pas
des deux
[Musique]
trucs
c'est le même c'est la même chose c'est
5 en fait tu peux vraiment là moi je me
le serais pris une fois tu as joué une
fois
surtout dans la finale dans l'autre
c'est 5
donc les C5
on est passé un peu vite pour rester sur
le direct de toute façon la tour à vide
ça fait bien la huitième
ça peut être un piège
c'est que
franchement l'échange des cavaliers tu
as rien contre
c'est un tour à deux c'est 5 on peut
remontrer en ralenti c'est à
l'impression quand même que voilà
il fait céder
et du coup c'était vite le match
quoi
tu vas ailleurs tu sais prendre BK
et ben très bien ok mais
résultat logique
c'est normal ça finit sur nul comme ça
donc on va est-ce qu'on fait une petite
pause allez on fait une petite pause
avant la pause dans 10 minutes a priori
donc 6 minutes exactement je vais mettre
le score à jour j'ai mis un virgule 6
c'est 1,6,5 si j'arrive
et on va se retrouver pour
la dernière ou avant dernière partie
puisque canule il y aura de nouveau un
magasin merci à tous on se retrouve très
vite à tout de suite
[Musique]
de nouveau de retour et ouais ça
enchaîne ça enchaîne
en fait ce serait très dynamique ce
serait vraiment sympa
le loser Q en fait
qui
est trop lourd
qui nous prend du temps et pas mal de
matchs
alors est-ce que ça peut être une
berlinoise et drôle et
il va faire je sais pas je suis pas dans
sa tête mais
non c'est trop cool
mais c'est plus une bonne année qui fait
plus trop
un anti
nul
parce que je me pose la question est-ce
que 40 peut vouloir juste nul en force
bah en gros c'est problème en faisant le
Marshall tu vas te faire un petit test
de mémoire et
G36
après je sais pas si c'est une bonne
idée ou pas
des variantes je sais plus c'est trop
longtemps mais bon j'ai trois c'est sûr
dommage 3 non 4 dessus
mais après je sais pas alors si c'est
je peux pas dire non mais je sais plus
exactement
mais bon il y a pas que en fait mais
n'importe quoi
je suis sûr que oui mais est-ce qu'il y
a une autre ligne
c'est un truc où tu fais genre faut
trois d'un F3 enfin tu rends ton pion
genre peut-être c'est fou trois fois
tu prends des cinq échanger d'âme tu
vois un peu cette finale longtemps
il y a pas une répète
comme ça à dire
vraiment juste un truc qui répète quoi
en force en dur
c'est une bonne illustration
tu as une idée c'est de faire ton H4
dégager la dame et où des fois dans mes
formes ça c'est autre chose avec le pion
des quatre là le bon coup des Noirs
c'est G5
parce que sur Full prend F5 double
Marshall où on explique ça ouais alors
après on avait montré surtout la partie
de marshallah
très haut niveau ou Marshall en fait
faisait pas 6 pour défendre le cavalier
mais repartait vers fcg4
et du coup il y a un intérêt à faire des
trucs
premier à 2,5
les deux hier on fait 10 minutes est-ce
que aujourd'hui il y en a un qui va
prendre le dire
ça fait très longtemps que personne
n'est rentré dans le
mais ouais donc en gros bon les blancs
ça paraît artificiel cette tournage 4
mais c'est bien d'avoir chasser la dame
de H3 qui est quand même est pénible ça
c'est quand même le roi et le problème
des blancs principalement les mars c'est
de d'arriver à développer les lames donc
là je sais pas si
on va fumer cette C5 ça paraîtra un plan
plus ou moins possible il y a peut-être
d'autres
intéressant parce que j'en ai discuté
avec bakit ça ce qu'il a regardé notre
vidéo sur le Gambie Marchal l'histoire
du marché et on en discutait et du coup
ça m'étonnerait pas que les
cubains qui jouent ce truc ils en ont
parlé ou que
Rosaire Raoul est déjà vu le Gambie
Marshall mais quelques vins aussi
en fait vu ça peut-être qu'en réalité
cubain j'en ai parlé quoi
[Musique]
un peu plus longue et c'est vrai que
d'habitude il évite
mentionné dans la vidéo je crois ah
ouais mais non mais on l'a mentionné ce
truc de cubes bien sûr
historique et travailler
et
hyper intéressant comme vidéo mais qui a
pas ouais c'est pas les trucs qui ont du
succès on devrait inventer des histoires
fausses en fait ça marche très bien ça
marcherait tellement mieux j'ai juste de
la merde et
les Cubains dans leur coin et c'était
concomitant
font chier tout le narratif en fait
attention truc de base que tu dis
bonsoir
[Musique]
et qui ont joué ça je rappelle plus une
partie
à plusieurs là comment s'appelle
consultatif je sais pas quoi
ils ont branlé mais ils ont joué ça quoi
ils étaient là
il y a un autre gars par correspondance
ou quoi mais lui aucun rapport et juste
clique en fait il a juste filé un pion
sans faire exprès
ah mais il y a des pièges et tout c'est
pas mal
ok chasse un peu la dame d'ici
probablement qu'elle est en dessin
pour ça que si tu veux vraiment la nulle
B3 5 ou 2 tu vas pouvoir faire mais je
pense qu'il y a vraiment pas faire
une fois
j'ai pressenti quand même
très bien
et ben ça va se jouer un Armageddon donc
on va voir leurs belles enchères etc etc
bon moi ça a pas dû à trop longtemps
celle-là du coup parti escamotée mais
pour mieux s'expliquer dans la prochaine
c'est avec les joueurs qui se copient
elle est vraiment bien ouais mais c'est
vrai comme histoire il se copier
vraiment
Russie Argentine non l'autre mais aussi
j'ai fait une vidéo il y avait Karya
King je sais pas
annule nul sans histoire et puis ça va
ça va revenir on va pas faire de pause
parce qu'on en sort donc deux
mais je sais pas du coup à quel point
c'est bien de balancer les blancs la
poubelle comme ça on saura s'il y a le
match ce sera bien sinon non mais il le
fait souvent en fait
je peux pas t'expliquer il aime bien il
est heureux
de faire nul et tu es pas éliminé dans
l'autre
un peu d'avance là il rêve d'avoir les
Noirs ils sont trop de faire mais bon
c'est dur de faire du sens en siffloto
en fait
celui-ci il est heureux de faire un
Armageddon
alors hier les deux ont pris des Noirs
ont moins de temps mais en cas de nul
ils ont gagné
l'URSS Argentine c'était quoi
l'homme
toi mais ça se trouve le 4e
mais ça fondamentalement par équipe tu
peux vraiment le faire
j'ai pensé depuis que j'étais petit
à poser question mais en fait on
pourrait pas faire ça et je sais pas
quel âge j'avais quoi du coup j'étais
ado quoi
tu fais pas alors
dans la partie de finir 30 secondes
chacun que bon tu as deux heures chacun
tu vas te faire défoncer
pour ceux qui comprendrais pas ce qu'on
raconte en fait imagine tu as un match
par équipe de 2 contre 2
ok une équipe qui est mémoire
et on joue
je joue pas trop j'attends un café C4 je
fais ces quatre
sens qui joue
5 le 5 en fait tu fais jouer les deux
mecs entre eux
et tu croises quoi donc voilà donc
normalement c'est interdit mais
j'ai le droit
du coup notre équipe sera un peu
le temps de copier mais bon après bon
cette note on est là quand on perdrait
normalement mais il y a quand même plus
d'incertitudes que si
le foot qui va commencer aussi 21h
peut-être 10
alors pourquoi je
sais pas
du début c'est vrai que l'armée du
looser
et
quoi et puis Armageddon de ça et puis là
bon c'est vrai
dû attendre on aurait dû attendre
l'autre partie de l'autre côté
[Musique]
dans la presse
ou même pas
pas gros sur mon favori mais
Arthur fils qui est en train de battre
botista au goutte
ou alors content pas plus mais pas moins
enfin je le connais pas Arthur fils
un jeune français
[Musique]
il tape quoi
c'est toujours cool de voir un Français
qui gagne de toute façon
sauf pour les FFL
[Musique]
bon je sais pas quand ça reprend mais
normalement ça va pas traîner trop trop
je sais pas
je pensais que c'était par minute mais
peut-être que là ils vont demander par
seconde pour faire un truc qui puisse
pas dire la même chose
c'est logique
[Musique]
à peine mais il est là
c'est vrai que ça pourrait être fait
avant
mais peut-être c'est fait avant le match
en fait peut-être avant ce que tu mets
de toute façon tu dois cliquer un truc
c'est pas censé être long de
sur du fait de la situation de la SSA
pour le foot abaissif non pas vraiment
enfin alors oui non mais la Ligue 1 je
m'en fous un peu mais je suis la Ligue 2
alors bon là c'est plus sur le bas de la
Ligue 2 pour le coup mais j'ai pas
délaissé l'équipe je suis allé au stade
je sais plus quand pour moi je dors
reprise après le hiclo
je regarde un peu les matchs à la télé
enfin les matchs c'est quand même des
purges mais
bon au même moment après le problème
c'est pas l'équipe
plus la gestion du club on va dire
mais écoute on va essayer de s'en sortir
cette année on verra bien mais tu vois
je vais pas m'arrêter de regarder parce
que ça joue mal et que des mauvais
résultats quoi c'est pas après on a
signal tu auras plus de mal à regarder
ouais alors peut-être qu'il y aura des
droits un truc je sais pas l'équipe
quelqu'un à nous le diffuser j'en sais
rien mais non j'espère qu'on va pas le
National quand même mais on a l'abri de
rien là
c'est pas du tout un sérieux improbable
alors je sais pas ils ont l'air très
heureux ils doivent être attendre les
résultats des enchères
j'en sais rien
c'est dommage qu'on ait pas les enchères
en live quoi
mais après comme c'est une enchère ça
dépend du temps tout dépend du temps en
fait
oui enfin je crois que les deux veulent
les Noirs mais c'est celui qui va
demander loin
national si ça descend national je suis
vraiment
mais
déjà c'est une équipe tu suis pas que
pour gagner et faire le malin dire
beaucoup plus fort on a acheté toute la
planète et on vous écrase et là tout le
temps quoi
ça va tout ce que j'ai connu c'est quoi
c'est
de monter en lien et
titre de Ligue 2 une coupe de la ligue
c'est pas le palmarès de ouf
[Musique]
stade au centre de formation on va
descendre en National tout va bien la
vie est belle
mais bon c'est sûr enfin je vous
souhaite pas de descendre mais si c'est
vous nous
choix de cœur sera vite fait la moutarde
pourrait neuf
9 c'est quand même c'est beau joueur
donc kikao obligation de gagner aussi à
noter que pour cette Armageddon il y a
plus le rajout de temps
aujourd'hui non non il y a pas d'erreur
il y a pas de rajout il y a pas les
trois secondes
et Magnus donc qui joue comme une
anglaise pour le moment
ouais du coup tu fais C4 tu transportes
tu peux aussi jouer avec ces quatre
j'imagine encore
instantanément
et à 4 rebondir
il va partir vers ces quatre pour
attaquer le pion le 5
normalement pour toucher le fou
j'ai 4 G3 et tu repars ou tu repars en
H5 G6 ou tu repars
à la maison
d'ailleurs et l'un et l'autre sont des
options c'est vraiment la même tu as
vraiment cette position avec un temps de
moi non c'est vraiment
ça c'est impressionnant normalement
mais c'est pas un choix bizarre
d'ouverture côté icaru non sûrement
parce qu'il veut vraiment jouer le lien
à fond ouais
mais du coup c'est un choix étrange la
partie d'avant je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est si c'est pour faire ça avec les
Blancs oui
tu as le droit de faire nul mais c'est
ça et tu refais après ouais tu peux le
faire deux fois d'affilée ouais
ouais mais il aime bien je sais pas il
regarde il est tout sourire je crois
qu'il est heureux
[Musique]
ça me fait plus de ça match
et après je le bats deux fois si ça
heureusement
il est très heureux de te dire ça
il veut quoi il veut F4 F5
d'abord pas forcément débarrasser du Fou
tu mets tes pièces tu veux peut-être B3
aussi tu renforcé la-bas voilà bah je
ferai mes trois mois c'est ce qu'il a
joué tempo
pour le moment très bien son temps il
réussit à rester à rester bien mais
attention je le répète pas de rajout de
temps dans cette Armageddon donc là
contrairement aux parties qu'on suit
toute la journée si tu commences à
t'approcher des deux trois minutes tu
peux commencer dans en danger et qui lui
conserve son temps qui ne se réduit pas
comme pot de chagrin ça prémouvant même
avec 13 37 ah il veut vraiment mettre un
maximum de pression
ok donc là il va cliquer non F4
[Musique]
c'est pas de problème
je pense faire F5
pareil simplement forcée parce que fou
prend ça donne la case 5
alors après si regarde un E5
intermédiaire ou quoi non et là tu as
peut-être 5 si on prend F5
tu as le droit c'est christmatique tout
à fait franchement pourquoi pas et ce
que je défends de ton
Pione qui emmerde je peux te dire un
truc quand je bossais avec muretas il
m'a dit que c'est le truc que je
trouvais systématiquement le plus vite
au final avion
en partie genre E5 puis on prend et F5
parce que dans les Écossais c'était un
peu ces idées là
des selles pions des fois E500
j'aime beaucoup le coup un très élégant
pour revenir vers G3 F5 c'est aussi très
bien joué
donc cavalier j'ai trois semble être un
coup
maintenant est très très élégant
mais même là je regarde encore en fait 5
puis on prend F5 si j'échange machin je
reviens avec le fou mais bon là ça
marche moins bien
[Musique]
en fait tu bloques tellement les pièces
à faire domino tour mais bon
c'est une question de goût vert c'est
toujours le mail de leur dieu
c'est intéressant
je veux dire je trouvais vraiment
mieux la première fois
pour toute façon aller en quatre façons
tu vas pas le faire tu vas pas fait une
faute tu as pas fait des fois mais bon
il part sur dame F3 cependant ça reste
une idée latente de la position à un
moment donné ça peut être bon je crois
qu'il va préparer gentiment vous deux
quand je veux
tu me places c'est avant je fais H5
j'aime bien la position des blancs
H1 avant peut-être te mettre un peu à
l'abri faire H5 et
avec les Noirs tu as peut-être pas de
plan en fait c'est ça le problème là
maintenant tu attends mais du coup on va
pouvoir t'amener toutes les pièces
donc on rappelle un Hikaru et dans
l'obligation de gagner cette partie pour
se qualifier pour la grande finale et le
perdant retournera dans le braquage de
ceux qui ont perdu qui ont déjà une vie
en moins et devra aller cracher demain
sur les coups de 19h entre le vainqueur
du match so Erika ici donc ce sera pas
un cadeau non dans les deux cas après ce
sera un joueur un petit peu affaibli de
par un match de deux heures voire deux
heures et demie avant cependant sauf
quand même se le taper de toute façon la
dernière fois il a joué le title
justement donc il fait pas peur
de rien il a 20 ans il a 19 ans ça
récupère vite le garçon est encore
vigoureux
on va voir est-ce que fou des deux tours
à vin va partir
possiblement
que 5 à 5
allez commence par roi H1 pourquoi pas
de toute façon c'était un coup qu'on
avait dans le plan
et alors la bonne chance Magnus parce
que rien faire ça donne pas envie
évidemment je sais que c'est toujours
dur il fait fou aussi alors ouais mais
c'est une concession
tu échanges une bonne pièce pourquoi une
bonne pièce que regarder les pions sont
sur case noir donc le foot de cases
blanches rayonne de mille feux il
rayonne un peu dans les pions adverse
mais il est rayonnants ce foulard c'est
un fou qui normalement est derrière la
structure mais bon une fois qu'il est
quand même déjà nettement mieux que on
ne connaît pas de la partie
mais en soi oui normalement avec les
Blancs crachent pas sur cet échange
tu as le droit de cracher dessus si tu
as envie de cracher mais bon
par la suite
super heureux il devait voir se préparer
son petit-fou des autres pour avoir 5
tranquille
grain de sable dans l'engrenage hyper
petit à petit son avance à la pendule
qui là pour la peine réduit comme peau
de chagrin ça y est on a réussi à la
placer cette peau
il a pas l'air
de se faire son clipse tranquille
mais bon
bah du coup
des deux
il aimerait pouvoir jouer de manière
plus offensive
et il perd hyper les 5 minutes qu'il
avait d'avance alors après il va
peut-être avoir une meilleure sensation
sur les coups qui va envoyer
il serait bien récap général du fonction
du temps alors tu peux trouver un sur le
site ouais il y a des articles
après chaque pause qu'on fait on fait
comme le dérouler donc après ça c'est
simple tu as deux vides dans le tournoi
tu as le droit de perdre deux fois donc
tant que tu as perdu deux fois tu
dégages tu peux perdre un match
en gros c'est
c'est assez simple au final ça c'est ça
les autres divisions
le fonctionnement de chaque division
n'est pas rentré dans le détail surtout
qu'on a pas les suivre donc en gros
c'est juste que de base il m'attend à
kif sur cheesecom le week-end dernier
alors ça allait aussi les règles sont un
petit peu complexes
après genre ce qualifie selon leur place
dans la ligue qui correspond ils ont un
division 2 divisions 3 et après tu
marques des points suivant les divisions
et là où tu finis voilà qui te
permettront d'aller à la grande finale
en fin d'année forcément en ligne point
de vision tu vas marquer plus de points
que pour une plastiques en deuxième ou
troisième division
ça c'est pour la simplicité du de la
chose finalement il a échangé mais il
s'est fait fixer les pions sur noir avec
son foot case noir
la série de coups semble plutôt en
faveur de Magnus quand même ouais ouais
de toute façon si on sentait que
après la question c'était ce qu'on fait
on prend F ou 5 il a décidé de 5 ça me
choque pas parce qu'en fait tu as moins
surveiller F4 qui ont passé alors les
Noirs ils aimeraient bien faire sur mon
cahier D8 qui va se replacer pour
bloquer aussi et la tour qui parlait
coulisser un peu vers B6 vers à 6 par
là-bas un peu nous en mettre un jour
mais toujours est-il que on n'a pas de
dernier modèle roi pour autant voir ça
ça joue la position c'est équilibré
tourgé un
encore peut-être pas H4 on partirait
vers H5 avec le cavalier espion nous
servent quelque part même de bouclier
on craint pas
ah il y a peut-être en plus sur H4 qui
est prime F5 tours F5 dmg4 double
ah ok
sur une dame des 5 du couteau j'ai 6
c'est très logique pour venir prendre
les devants sur cette colonne
à la partie reste très équilibrée Magnus
qui a un petit avantage de par le fait
que il ait le droit de faire nul des
cars
5 puis on prend le 5 dame C6 échec on va
vous le montrer donc ça serait la
variante qui gagnerait mais on peut pas
faire tourner H2 pour cacher
qui fait mal
écoute c'est trouvable si on cherche non
mais en fait c'est toujours interlogan
de voir une dame et un roi sur une même
colonne donc c'est cavalier prend E5
prépare-toi
64 mais bon faites qui roulait raté
c'est pas si simple ça va pas trop mais
il met en place quand même le setup
problème
[Musique]
alors ça perd pas mais ça fait nul et du
coup il fait de la F3 qui est français
de ouais là il carou qui est en train de
craquer
ça peut pas aller ah non ben
du coup
la situation de match de
ce qui est vraiment il y a rien à faire
analyser on va regarder la partie
que 30 secondes de retard est un peu
plus
ouais ça a l'air difficile
car ou qui s'est raté
un le fait de pas avoir joué
de chance quoi
non mais la question c'est pas la bonne
décision et je sais pas ce qu'il a mal
en fait
ça avait l'air d'être fort
en tout cas ça avait l'air de donner une
position vraiment qui joue qui jouait
facile et vraiment dame C6 bien jouer
Hikaru écureuil
il sait qu'il est obligé d'échanger les
dames
et il sait qu'il est obligé de faire ça
alors les Caro excellent défenseur donc
s'il devait simplement faire nul il
pourrait peut-être en confiance mais là
il est obligé de gagner le sol petit
espoir pour
la pendule il y a peut-être le fait que
Magnus du coup la joue pas tout à fait
pareil vu que
vu que match nul lui suffit mais il va
réussir à mettre une cabine tour en B7 à
bouffer un pion et peut-être à le
pousser
il a encore une petite chance
Ikao
8 tu reprends à 7 et ce qui peut
à 34 c'est encore beaucoup quand même
pour Magnus
comme ça
j'arrive pas à comprendre exactement le
souci
peut-être tu auras 6 Roger un tour
c'est à quoi je pensais c'est si grave
[Musique]
et cavalier
là au moins le fou des blancs va
s'occuper du pendais la tour en bassette
elle est pas mal placé c'est pas fait
encore dès que tu fais
c'est bien joué d'avoir décalé le pion
lui déjà qu'on prenne en 6
on perdra un tempo pour revenir en 7e
attention à trois minutes pour Magnus
alors évidemment un 3 et en trois plus
zéro on arrive à jouer c'est le temps
qu'on a pour faire une partie complète
correcte normalement mais attention
quand tu fais tu reprends à 6 et après
on voudra te reprocher ici si tu en
penser 6 à 5 à 6 le roi arrivant F3 et
ça peut jouer plus le temps
descend puis on peut être sous pression
qui fait à 5
fou maintenant
la dernière séquence de coût est quand
même de nouveau plutôt en faveur du
carreaux même s'il reste derrière
évidemment des trois attention se font
en C3 ça peut faire des accidents
peut-être
il va regarder calculer à mon avis un
petit coup franc à 5 est-ce que il aura
le temps x 8 c'est 3 tu vois tu reprends
à 4 si c'est chèque ce genre de choses
ou toi tu veux prendre Jessie c'est
qu'on s'est amener 3 aussi et comment ça
à courir c'est ce qui fait
alors est-ce que des G5 peuvent être
intéressants pour essayer tout disloquer
peut-être pas tout de suite mais roi G73
on a quoi de moi on a deux pions de
moins mais il y en a un deux trois qui
peuvent tomber rapidement on va tous
tomber en même temps malheureusement
mais bon ils peuvent tomber femme mais
surtout en fait on peut faire tomber
rapidement des trois et A5 ce qui nous
donnerait virtuellement un pion de plus
donc
je crois j'ai 7 je suppose roi F3 mais
attention la tour va pouvoir se décaler
vers des 4 c'est ce qui Caro
semble venir de voir
cette tour en Descartes qui peut être un
vrai problème
ce qu'on a vu on a vu une petite une
petite
de mécontentement
va calculer ça va prendre des pions et
mécontents là
attention Fab
quand même
F3 tour des quatre trois tours C4 3D 3
tours à 4 ou 3 et c'est tout misé sur le
Pione
ça paraît une mise risquée ouais c'est
optimiste quoi
[Musique]
on voit la Hikaru qui commence à
désespérer donc il va essayer de troquer
le pion c'est contre le pion a la tour
qui annonce
quand arrive le foussette aussi c'est
réactive ouais ça a l'air d'être perdu
maintenant et Caro qui souffle
il calcule pas bien
dans cette partie
le pion qui arrive en C4 tour à 7 à 5 il
essaye d'envoyer le va tout il peut
peut-être encore faire tourner
à ces quatre des trois contre
il pousse mais il se rend pas trop la
tête de voir si une défense ou pas
il a le côté de large de pouvoir juste
faire nul s'il y a besoin de faire nul
et ça va ça va s'incliner probablement
côté
Ikao mais il sera pas éliminé du tournoi
là il est il est dégoûté de sa partie et
de sa performance
mais il ne sera pas éliminé car où il se
reviendra demain contre les perdants
pour revenir dans le tournoi des
gagnants
de gagner
il a juste ses pièces
carreaux quand même qui est encore un
micro espoir
pour B7
il va essayer de s'approcher
et tout qui disparaît
recette échec pour le plaisir
il propose lui et il accepte de
s'incliner bon bah une histoire de
qui qui s'offre qui s'octroît une
journée de repos demain et une deuxième
vie en finale que ce soit Hikaru ou un
autre Magnus Carlsen aura encore la
possibilité de perdre un match pour
s'imposer dans ce tournoi en tout cas
impressionnant
performance du joueur norvégien qui
avait quand même dominé au point ce
match Fab notamment les deux premières
parties clairement après c'était revenu
dans le match mais
bon dans l'ensemble numérique donc
victoire méritée les amis on se
retrouvera demain donc pour deux matchs
exceptionnels Fabien Erika easy contre
sceaux puis le 24
parties hein si on a bien lu le
changement de règle dans le règlement de